at the end of time
[Music]
13. o'clock
well hey everybody yeah and I am asking
hey for a change yeah that's good we
don't want like the people in the video
next door that would be super funny if
we got somebody in here that would like
push you into the [__] head of the
video we have to do that one of these
days yeah oh my goodness so uh yeah I
kind of like what you did with the
lighting back there he was messing
around yeah you fixed it yeah I mean we
still have we've moved some stuff around
but because we used to have a blue and
green one back there but now it's over
there so you know what I mean but
whatever it doesn't really make that
much difference
two blue and green ones yeah yeah but I
mean there was one behind this box
though there is one there is there no no
it's no on the floor yeah okay let me
put it in its proper position there well
no I mean I think there was another one
oh women yeah that's right because I
moved that one yeah because you moved
out that's what I'm saying yeah that's
what that was that's what I'm saying no
I'm not crazy that's what you're talking
about
uh Zach says Jenny why are the curtains
over there made of trash bags what
are you talking about the room look
they're not made of trash bags they're
made of curtains yeah
and they're red trash bags aren't red so
I don't really know but that's like a
what do they call that thing a valance
or whatever
the room looks bigger too I wonder why I
think it's just because the angle is
slightly different yeah either that of
the rim is expanding like some kind of
weird Lovecraft yeah it's actually
further away than it looks it is yeah
this is actually like a pretty big race
you know what I mean because you guys
are only seeing like a little bit of it
it actually like there's another half of
it like over there Spock is actual size
he is he is I stand next to him he's
[__] taller than me pretty much his
head's a little small though I feel like
yeah is it is your head the same size as
fox head
wait I can't see you you're out you're
in the next door video
okay there you go I don't understand
next to it
put your arm around him now give him a
kiss
[Laughter]
yeah I mean he's got some narrow ass
shoulders though he does yeah yeah yeah
I tried to stand next to him and I'm off
camera I can't see though
I know John Gore said I kind of dig the
black trash bag a sec I do too uh
actually Kim I know this everybody's
like joking about the trash bag even
though like I said they're they're like
red with
black they look like black checkers from
here but they're actually like mesh it's
red it's but they're red it's red and
red is what they are it's red on red
Zach says by the way show topic
suggestion the liminal spaces phenomenon
I was actually thinking about doing a
show like that I'm not really sure how I
would approach the topic what the hell
is that but it's well liminal spaces are
kind of like
um you know if you watch dead Mall
videos yeah it's kind of anything that
is sort of like an in-between space or
like a abandoned space like that and
people get these particular feelings
from them there's this whole thing going
on in
um uh in horror where people doing
something called back rooms where
there's all these like creepy videos and
like args and stuff like that of
somebody like exploring these back rooms
like [__] like behind the mall and stuff
like that where there's like nothing and
they're just endless and like it just
keeps going and stuff so people are like
really fascinated by that like nowadays
I used to have dreams being in Endless
houses yeah I did too yeah so like I
said I think that's maybe why people are
so into it I think that's why people so
are so into like dead Mall videos at
abandoned places videos and stuff like
that because of that whole liminal
spaces kind of thing
um Josie says love those glasses Jenny
thank you very much yeah I've had these
for a little while I'll give her those
yeah yeah yeah he bought them for me I
was skeptical because I was like well I
don't know if I really like these big
ass
glasses I don't think they'd look good
on my face but they do actually because
I kind of like the smaller or cat eye
ones you know what I mean murder Hornets
in my apartment is a back room
so it's just like empty and it never
ends you just keep going through the
corridors and then every now and then
there's a monster or something but yeah
um so yeah today we're going to be
talking about yet another depressing
topic but like I said um
the True Crime ones as depressing as
they are are not gonna lie my favorite
ones to do you know what I mean and I
knew about this case but I didn't know
all of the details about it the weird
thing about this is that even though in
some circles this girl she's not a girl
anymore obviously but she was a girl
when when she did it
um she's kind of known as like the
grandmother of school shootings like the
OG school shooter I mean technically
there were a couple of school shootings
prior to this
but when you're talking about your sort
of like modern school shootings which
you know you see depressingly like a lot
of nowadays this was kind of the first
one like that and this happened in 1979
and very very unusually was perpetrated
by as I said a teenage girl uh you
hardly ever I mean girls women don't
commit uh you know serial killings and
stuff like that to anywhere near the
same frequency as men do or boys and men
do and specifically like mass shootings
of this kind is all is overwhelmingly
like a male phenomenon uh so it's very
very unusual for a girl to do something
like this and the reason that this got
so famous at the time even though I feel
like it's probably not as famous
nowadays which I think is really strange
because this was kind of the first one
um was that she was so [__]
callous about like the way she talked
about it and even to this day because
the spoiler alert she's still in prison
um she's still alive but um she never
really came up with an adequate reason
why she did it and so
over the years I feel like a lot of
people have kind of speculated like what
exactly her deal was or why she just
decided to Crazy do this one day
probably just crazy but well I mean not
exactly it's kind of like a lot more
complicated than that but we'll like get
into it there's a lot of weird [__]
going on with
her and like her family Dynamic and it's
I don't know it's just like a very very
strange School massacres there people
act like this is new it's not new
it goes all the way back to the 1800s
um they've had kids show up just old
school houses in the 1800s
even out like in the uh in Frontier
areas
come shoot the teacher and a couple of
students and themselves yeah there I was
I was listening to a documentary about
this
and they mentioned a couple there
weren't a [__] ton uh there was actually
one in the 1700s that I think like
Native Americans did and that was just
they didn't shoot kids or anything but
they just like went into school and like
killed the school master I think and
then there was one in the 1800s where
they came in and kind of like opened
fire at the playground or something like
that but it's like I mean they were
pretty rare and like I said when you're
talking about like modern ones like like
you see nowadays this was kind of the
first one like that it's hard to have
crimes like this in very low density
population areas they're just the the
statistics are against it
Zach says uh fun fact the way I learned
of this story was a girl who builds
places associated with crimes and
paranormal stuff in The Sims and tells
the story about them oh yeah I've heard
of that I've heard of that
Channel
um I did see I didn't watch it because
there are like quite a few YouTube
videos about this like not a lot that
have a lot of uh traction but there was
kind of like a lot of smaller ones and
somebody I didn't watch it but like it
was a guy that I guess goes and visits
like areas of like where crimes happened
and so he did a video where he went to
this house because evidently
I mean as far as I'm aware the house is
still there and the crazy thing about it
is that which we'll get into in a little
bit but
um her dad he's dead now but her dad
lived in that same house like until he
died like the house that she
shot from which is
weird
um but yeah so like I said this whole
the whole situation with the family is
weird I don't really know what to
believe to be honest with you
um
but and like I said anything you know
I'm just putting this out there like
like right away is that anytime we talk
about because we talk about a lot of
serial killers and all this kind of
stuff I mean if you guys are around here
you know and we always kind of talk
about like reasons why they did it or
you know what maybe was the matter with
them or like you know [__] up [__]
that happened to them when they were
kids like maybe they were abused and
stuff like that and when we talk about
that it's like I'm not in any way like
trying to excuse what they did it's like
I'm just trying to understand or like
contextualize it and that's the same
thing here I kind of feel like the
reason that I find Brenda Spencer so
fascinating not only because she's a
teenage girl that did this horrible [__]
um you know which is very unusual but
also that she can't really come up with
a reason like they didn't really seem to
be a reason why she just particularly
this one day did that and the fact that
she's been in prison all this time and
she was up for parole several times but
they haven't given it to her yet so
she's still in there I don't imagine
that they'll probably probably ever give
it to her she's imprisoned in California
and they said it's very unusual for
anybody that is in there for murder
to get parole so they said you know uh
everyone's like we would be very
surprised if she ever got out and it's
because too even though she seems to now
Express remorse for what she did she
doesn't really seem to be taking
responsibility for it because every time
she has a parole hearing
um she tries to come up with some other
reason or some other excuse like why she
did it that is
seems calculated to make people
sympathize with her more and so the
parole board have kind of got to a point
where they're like well you know she's
obviously not owning up to what she did
and so we don't think we think that she
might still be a danger because she's
not really seemed to be taking
responsibility for what she did she's
always still trying to like excuse it so
you know but like I said we'll get into
that too murder Hornet said she's still
in jail yes she is
um like I said she I think her last
parole hearing she had one in 2019
um or she was up for parole in 2019 and
I think she personally like waved it
like said she didn't want it and um then
at that point like they they kept
offering it to her like subsequent years
so I think they did offer one in 2022
but as far as I know
um she did waive that one as well so
maybe at this point she doesn't want to
get out I'm not really sure you have to
think like she's been in prison since
she was 16 years old in 1979 yeah what's
she gonna do when she gets out I mean
and the thing about it is that
um
you know even though I I just kind of
feel like that I saw like a documentary
where they interviewed like a lot of the
family members of the victims and stuff
like that and they're like you know we
just wish that she'd got the death
penalty like they don't want her to ever
get out
um because they're still
afraid of her I don't really think that
I don't know it's hard to say like I've
seen some more recent interviews with
her and she doesn't really seem
dangerous per se but it is troublesome
like if it's troubling like the fact
that she doesn't seem to be like really
taking responsibility what are we
talking about are we saying that you
know that they picked on her is that was
that is that what is that her excuse no
okay no she came up with yeah she came
up with some weird [__] than that okay
this wasn't a case this wasn't like
columbine or anything like that where
the kids were like oh they got bullied
and stuff I as far as I know
um she wasn't like a popular kid she was
kind of like one of those Wallflower
type girls that was you know real quiet
and introverted and stuff but as far as
I know
um she didn't get like actively bullied
not that I ever heard of anyway but
um she seemed to have like some other
problems but I'm not really entirely
sure exactly like what like how it all
came together and culminated in that
particular thing you know
korean-american kid what was his name
okay I think one of his name was Cho
he was the one that dressed up he
thought everybody was [__] making fun
of him and he dressed up his little
tactical gear
when it shot the place up it was a
university
remember that yeah yeah that's right
yeah and he made a whole video and he
sounded serious as hell you know you
have laughed at me for the last time
he's going on he was almost like a Star
Trek villain he was like some out of
Star Trek
and nobody even knew who that dude was
nobody was making fun of him it was all
in his head
see I kind of feel like Elliot Roger was
like that too where like he thought I
mean these people have like weirdly they
have really really low self-esteem but
then conversely they also have like a
really really inflated sense of their
own self-importance like they think that
everybody is conspiring against them or
paying attention to them when really
like no one knows who the [__] they are
it's like they're just another person I
mean the narcissist the level of
narcissism yeah that has to be present
for you to like actually think that
anybody really gives that much of a [__]
about you like just random people that
you've never met yeah that Korean dude
was like the whole world is looking at
me
see that's mental illness yeah that's
mental illness you've all mocked me for
the last time yeah yeah like I said that
Elliot Roger was like that too and that
like blew my mind that he was actually
saying it's like he would actually like
girls that didn't even like [__] know
him like he was just some random dude
and he'd be like well they are actively
like [__] with me because they're not
coming up and like offering [__] to me
like you know what I mean it was like
that and I'm just like the [__] are you
saying like what is the matter with you
yeah that dude was obviously mentally
ill why would you think that anybody
that doesn't know you just like a random
person would give a single fart about
you like nobody does they don't you did
Elliot Rogers did we did yeah yeah we
did we haven't done that guy we haven't
done that other guy yeah Joel yeah I
think his name is
yeah it's Korean name but uh and then
all the Korean Americans thought there
was gonna be reprisals and they're like
what the [__] you talking about
you know it's like everybody shoots [__]
the schools up yeah crazy around here
they didn't [__] blame Korean
Americans for that that's another
terrible thing to say nobody does happen
I mean statistically it's rare still but
it does happen like way more than
obviously it should what's that it
shouldn't happen at all like school
shooting yeah yeah I'm talking about
reprisals yeah the Koreans were off
though should we all leave the country
you know I mean I can't blame them for
thinking that because look what happened
to like people that even looked vaguely
Arab after 9 11 you know they got
[__] murdered in the street and [__]
like that so you know what I mean
that's what I mean that happened a lot I
wrote about some of those cases and
faceless melon there was like a whole
run of them like people just like
randomly getting shot like random hate
crimes and stuff it was [__] up
um yeah John Gore said she's thoroughly
institutionalized by now I mean she's
got to be like I said she's never had
like a normal adult life outside of
prison she's been in jail since she's
been 16. yeah um
yeah Zach says in my experience
Wallflowers are either the coolest
people ever or to be avoided at all
costs and you can never be sure which
they are yeah that's also true in my
experience um yeah a lot of like I said
you can't just be like oh they're loner
weirdos because some loner weirdos are
actually really awesome people but like
you said there's really no in between is
there they're like they're like really
awesome loader weirdos or they're kind
of like
potential serial killer your weirdness
Dahmer was a loader weirder right and
see that's what I mean so Brenda Spencer
was a loner weirdo too but obviously
she's we don't us other loner weirdos
don't want to associate with those kind
of loner weirdos Okay and like nobody
does dombern is bucket fully they're
cool okay yeah His Bucket Full of dicks
His Bucket Full of dicks yeah old bucket
full of dicks dog Jeffrey bucket yeah
Jeffrey [__] buckets that's
what they should start calling him yeah
Jeffrey bucket of dicks donor Dahmer Mr
88 said uh well actually Zach asked it
uh I Googled her once doesn't she kind
of look like Janis Joplin she does a
little bit she does a little bit
um Mr 88 said she was a misanthropic
grunge a decade before it was cool
yeah she was way ahead of her time she
was like a hipster uh her Detachment was
really weird yeah that was one thing
that really struck me about and we'll
get into this in a bit but like while
the
shooting situation was still going on
um some reporters actually got her on
the phone like she was talking to them
on the phone and like some of the [__]
she said she just like obviously did not
she just thought it was a [__] Lark
man she was having a great time she
thought it was funny huh yeah and it was
just it's funny that when women that
it's a woman that killed this way
because it's atypical usually that's
what I mean it's very very unusual you
hardly ever ever see yes usually female
multiple murderers she's going to be a
poisoner or an angel of death in a way I
mean overwhelmingly that's what you see
or it's something like you know
Munchausen by proxy or something like
that or usually and we've talked about
this before too usually women killers
they tend to kill for quote-unquote
practical reasons which means money or
um they kill family members is usually
what they do or like you said you know
they'll usually use poison or something
you don't usually see like violent
Killers it happens I'm not saying it
doesn't but um Mass Shooters like this
like very I don't even know what the
percentage is it's got to be vanishingly
small or the baby killers like that oh
woman in London that used to [__]
just pretend like she was adopting kids
out to [__] adoption services but
she's really just throwing them into the
Tims and she was killing them killing
them yeah yeah I mean you have people
like you know Belle gunnis or somebody
like that I mean she was just killing
people she wasn't getting off on it I
don't think she was just killing people
and like cash in their [__] Social
Security checks and [__] like that just
throwing them out in the [__] hog
trough or whatever the [__] she was
doing you know what I mean
uh kalon hicken said narcissism can be a
byproduct of prolonged self-isolation
yeah that's true the mind trying to
defend itself from Deep existential
dread that might have been Brenda
Spencer's uh problem too because she did
seem very
isolated in a lot of ways and like I
said we'll get into her family situation
I'm not entirely sure whether she was
physically abused or not um she did make
some claims in that regard much later
but I don't know how true they are I
like I said I'm not in the habit of
uh doubting people's allegations of
sexual abuse because that's like not a
good you know that's a slippery slope to
go down but the fact that she didn't
bring it up until many many years later
um just kind of like gives me pause you
know what I'm saying just and she did it
when she was like at a parole hearing
and like she hadn't brought it up prior
yeah
kind of like uh based on what she said
there I'm listening to this audiobook
on YouTube called rape of the mind it's
real fascinating it's written in the
1950s by um I think he's a Dutch author
Juiced something or other MD and uh it's
a book about mind control mind control
and brainwashing
and he talks about
mental illness and catatonia
and that's like what she said some
people are so sensitive
to Life's troubles that they decide
to retreat from reality Sometimes using
drugs but sometimes just using their
willpower they TR they Retreat from
reality and start living in a fantasy
world
and they can train their brains
eventually
uh to live so deeply in fantasy that it
starts coming across as schizophrenia
and it becomes schizophrenia
schizophrenics are like that and as it
goes even deeper deeper it becomes
Catatonia they don't even eat you got to
feed them
and they retreated into a uh basically a
Nirvana a self-controlled heaven
and you can put two catatonic people
right next to each other and they won't
ever talk or no interactions really
maybe maybe something real small but
then there's
if they talk the interaction is not deep
it's real superficial sometimes totally
unrelated one guy talking about a
cigarette the other guy talk about cars
you know what I mean and
but it's fascinating it's in the mind
folding in on itself like that
which is partially what happens it's
part of the process that causes
brainwashing and mind control to work
I'm still listening to it it's a good
book real good and about how you can
totalitarian regimes can do it in Mass
on people entire populations Soviet
Union and you're talking about you know
Nazi Germany is what he was talking
about how they were using mind control
and they know they're doing it it's
psychiatrists they're psychologists
using it propaganda techniques to do it
fascinating Books use for free on
YouTube I encourage people to listen to
it murder Hornet said she had a typical
70s look yeah she did look a little bit
she looked kind of like a tomboy
um and she was a self-admitted tomboy
like she was into kind of boy stuff and
like to wear like kind of military
fatigues and things like that
um Zach says uh oh God I just found a
90s prison photo of her and she I know
what photo you're talking about and she
has a lesbian buzz cut mixed with a
mullet I don't think I've ever seen a
mullet a woman with a mullet before yeah
oh I have oh yeah you come to South but
uh yeah you'll see you'll see a lot of
them up north too yeah she and that's an
old photo like I've seen a more recent
photo of her I think the most recent one
I saw was from 2021 and she's like
unrecognizable like she's in her 50s now
I guess but yeah she's I mean she porked
out like big time yeah because when she
was 16 she was a tiny tiny she was very
very thin John and she's real short
she's only my height she's like five
foot two John goris points out yeah
American Americans has done it too
they're doing it now doing through
corporate propaganda
um channels to television you can see
you can plainly see that they're using
those same techniques news
adult CIA okay good murder Hornet said
didn't you all do a show on that
thallium poisoner in the UK yeah we did
um we've done a show on like several
different poisoners because I'm
fascinated by poisoners they're probably
my favorite kind of serial killer oh
that's a [__] up thing to say I don't
know like I'm really like fascinated by
people that poison
and we did a show about what was that
dude's name uh he was actually for a
time was one of the Jack the Ripper Subs
but I mean you know who wasn't a Jack
the Ripper suspect during that I was
probably a Jack Ripper suspect and I
wasn't even born yet but um but yeah he
was like uh Thomas Neil cream right was
he the one that was the poisoner that
was the I think we did a show about him
but that was like a long time ago
that was a long time ago
um let me see what there was something
else that I wanted to [__]
um Zach says back in the 70s she was
actually really pretty too is that weird
to say
yeah I mean I thought she was an okay
looking
girl I mean she didn't
on the um I don't know if this was on
the Wikipedia page or on Murderpedia or
somewhere like that
um there was a quote that one of her
classmates said that she was quote
unquote really crummy looking
um but I don't know if that meant like
what she actually looked like or just
that she dressed kind of yeah maybe you
didn't take him because she out well I
mean she looked clean but she just
always wore like kind of baggy oh okay
you know she just dressed real baggy and
she had like always had a beanie on and
yeah he means sloppy yeah I thought
that's maybe it would yeah because I was
like well she looks okay to me like she
doesn't look she's not super ugly or
anything she was grunge before Grudge
yeah so yeah she looked basically like a
90s grunge kid like a little skinny girl
with a little Beanie and like baggy
fatigues on
um I saw pictures of her she was cute
yeah
said I didn't know she was a ginger
always seem black and white photos yeah
she had like uh actually that's about
the same color that's my natural hair
color yeah too no relation
but yeah she has about the same hair
color as me
um but yeah so okay so should we talk
about the shooting first and then go
back and talk about her or should we
talk about her first
um do you think what is like this let's
talk about the shooting because the best
way to approach double back the male
strategy would be talking about the
shooting first and then you go back and
talk well see that's why I'm asking you
because I figured you'd be like well
let's do it the Dudley way
to answer John uh yeah um
um the Unabomber Ted Kaczynski I think
his name was
um yeah he was MK Ultra yeah we did a
show about him did a show about it not
too long ago yeah he was involved in the
MK Ultra
experiments when he was in the
University
can you read his stuff man he's he's
right about a lot of stuff I don't put
his methods were wrong
he just waited he'd have his own YouTube
channel he'd be [__] famous be on
Infowars or some [__]
but uh yeah a lot of things he was
worried about
his ultimate fear was that eventually
that they would
corporations would basically make
artificial people using genomes and
artificial wombs and stuff and sell
human beings as products then it would
eventually get to that
China would do that
I don't know I think it would be too
illegal in the United States right now
to do that but he's talking about
replicants basically replicants like
from [__] Blade Runner and AI taken
over and [__] which yeah okay that's all
you that's really what he was worried
about
among a bunch of other stuff
Zach said also is this where the I hate
Mondays quote comes from I don't know I
think that was the thing before that but
um
if you know the Boomtown rat song which
is called I Don't Like Mondays it's a
great song by the way uh and it came out
in 1979 actually 1979 or 1980 like not
long after this happened was uh inspired
by this it was about Brenda Spencer so
um yeah and the thing about it is that I
heard that after that song came out it I
don't think it um got in the charts in
the U.S but it got a lot of radio play
over here like in bigger cities like
bigger markets but it was like a number
one hit in like the UK and like a bunch
of other countries in Europe and stuff
and um I think either Brenda Spencer
I don't remember if she wrote to Bob
Geldof
um personally or if she just said this
in her interview but she said that she
was so happy that Bob Geldof had written
I Don't Like Mondays about her because
it made her famous and then Bob Geldof
was like oh [__] maybe I shouldn't yeah
[__] song you know what I mean
because that's probably their most
famous song I feel like it wasn't the
first one I heard of there's actually
the first one I heard of theirs was up
all night which is also a good song but
yeah I Don't Like Mondays is about here
and in my opinion I think it's hard for
Bob gildoff to make anybody famous
because he's not that famous well he
wasn't he he wasn't famous here but he
was hugely hugely famous in Europe yeah
yeah well that's what I mean and that um
that song I Don't Like Mondays I think
the US was pretty much the only country
where that wasn't like a huge hit and it
did get ready I mean it was like number
one in like 40 countries or some [__]
like that like so it was a massive see
that's what I mean like that's it well
yeah yeah well I kind of feel like
Americans like think like oh everything
like oh well we don't know who it is so
they're not famous but I'm like there's
like many many other countries where
shit's famous but like the boom
in the UK I knew some of their songs
because they played them on MTV like
back in the old days but I didn't hear
that one until like a little bit later
but they used to play up all night all
the time like back in the early 80s so
but they played um I Don't Like Mondays
on a lot of radio stations and matter of
fact they played it so much that the
families of the victims were kind of
like can we not like we really don't
want to hear the song like be reminded
of like [__] our loved ones dying
every time we hear this [__] song but
you know what I mean what are you gonna
do what are you gonna do
um yeah Camp guy knows this song let's
talk about the silicone chip inside her
head which uh she didn't have that but
um because they're talking about her
being a Manchurian Candidate however
they did find out later that um she well
we'll get into that that she maybe did
have some
I don't want to say brain damage that
seems a little excessive but you know
so here's what happened
so it's the morning of January 29th 1979
and in case I did not mention it this
happened in uh San Diego
now uh Brenda Spencer actually lived in
a house across the street from Cleveland
Elementary School named after Grover
Cleveland who is a president if you're
not from the United States yeah and
Grover was a muppet was a mother and
McCarver was a muppet those two things
are completely unrelated
groper is probably my favorite Muppet
although I don't know maybe Oscar's up
there too I like Galapagos yes
oh bird do you remember like when Sesame
Street first started didn't there for am
I tripping but for a long time everybody
else on Sesame Street thought that big
bird was high because like he was the
only one that could see Snuffleupagus or
Snuffleupagus would only show himself to
Big Bird so everyone thought he was
making it up it was like his imaginary
friend yeah and then finally later on
they're like oh my God he is real yeah
am I crazy or did that really happen I
think that did happen but I don't think
it happened for very long okay a couple
episodes because I was pretty sure I
mean I was yeah pretty little like when
I saw him
I'm pretty sure that like for a long
time they thought he was like [__]
hallucinating I forgot the plots to
[__] the Sesame Street Series yeah I
mean there were I mean it wasn't plots
but they just kind of had care they just
like hung out you know what I mean like
they had their little characters and
they just
yeah two
two little bites
[__] this [__] man come on
well I just want well because you
brought up stuff and I was thinking
about that the other day because
somebody at work was talking about
Sesame Street and I was like I thought
it was like yeah they thought he was
like pretending that Snuffleupagus
wasn't real because nobody ever saw him
um
let's see
um Mr 88 said even the Beatles they were
hugely famous in England in early 63 but
had zero attraction in the US then they
finally caught on yeah I mean there was
a lot of stuff that was hugely famous in
the UK
yeah Jeff ER thank you Jeffy art says
people believed he was an imaginary
friend yeah that's right that's what I
thought Maria was the first human to
meet him yes I'm that guy I remember
Maria yeah Maria and who was the other
Luis was the guy and then remember Mr
Hooper because he died on there and that
was like a big thing
um Zach says the only reference I've
seen to that was a Family Guy joke where
Big Bird was a meth addict and covered
his sores and itchy
man I used to love Sesame Street it's
still good I would still I would still
like let kids watch it nowadays
um yeah
that's really funny but you think of all
this old [__] man well you're the one
that I'm touching you're the one that
brought up Grover so that's why because
we were talking about Grover Cleveland
Grover was not president of the United
States although how [__] awesome
would that be yeah I would love Grover
to be president yeah that would be so
cool I was thinking a Sigmund and the
sea monster where all that [__] oh yeah
I remember that show too yeah yeah I
remember that show too was it Rip Taylor
was he on there too oh yeah throwing
glitter and everything man that [__]
was on everything he was Queen of the
70s he was yeah he was on all the shows
because he had queen or whatever
[__] with his [__] magic wand and
[__] throwing glitter
yeah starfish and [__] gay as [__] he
was yeah
you couldn't get he'd be any gayer than
that Zach
yeah I mean that's like the aspirational
he's like the aspirational guy yeah
that's like Pete gay that was like 70s
meme yeah
he was an old Queen yeah and knew it
just took the [__] to the [__] Hill
funny though yeah [__] was funny
hilarious funny hilarious comedian
Jeffy art said oh and here reminded me
of this Luis and Maria were married in
real life yeah that's right uh yeah Luis
passed away recently that's right I
remember that I remember that that's I
think that's what got me thinking about
it maybe
but yeah
so uh so yeah so this is January 29th
1979 kind of a cold morning in Sam in
San Diego
so uh Brenda
she decides that uh she's going to
apparently like her dad goes in she
lived with her dad which we'll get into
like the whole family Dynamic like after
we talk about the shooting because Tom
said we had to talk about the shooting
first because that's the Dudley way well
yeah because I don't know anything about
the details of the shooting okay so I
imagine I'm just going to say probably
the average person probably doesn't
either so let's go to the shooting yeah
like I said I feel like this isn't as
well known as like more recent school
shootings even though this was kind of
like sort of that's the OG like school
shooting I guess if you want to put it
like that but um yeah so her dad goes in
to wake her up and she's already up and
dressed and stuff but then she's just
kind of like you know what I don't feel
that good I don't really want to go to
school today and he's like okay whatever
um he was just going to work and he was
kind of used to her
um not wanting to go to school I mean
we'll get into it later but well great
is she she was a well she was 16 so I
guess she was probably a junior probably
like a junior I imagine she was probably
a junior and she didn't obviously she
didn't go to the school that she was
shooting out because that was in
elementary school she went to Patrick
Henry High School
but the one the elementary school was
across the street it's literally like
right across somebody else's school yeah
she had lived across the street from
that school like pretty much her whole
life but it was an elementary school
that she shot at not a high school okay
like she but yeah she was truant a lot
because she started getting in trouble
and [__] like that so um so her dad was
just kind of like whatever like you
don't have to go to school I think that
she claimed she had PMS now I don't
really know I was listening to a really
good there's a really good podcast
um it was Once Upon a Crime and she did
like an hour-long breakdown of this case
and I was listening to it in the car
on the way home and she was saying that
Brenda had like really really bad
um like PMS like debilitating
um which you know she wasn't saying that
as like an excuse for anything but she
was saying that was one of many like
kind of health problems that she had and
so that was the reason why her dad
didn't really think anything of you know
her saying oh I have really bad PMs and
he's just like okay just whatever just
stay home so I guess she was kind of
like planning on doing this so like I
said it's a Monday morning
so she essentially it's
um the school I guess what they did like
the um the classes started at either
eight or eight thirty I can't remember
but they would have the gate closed and
like the little kids would line up and
then the principal
his name was Burton ragg he would come
and open the gate and like let all the
kids inside like to go to their classes
so that's basically what was happening
like all the kids were lining up outside
so at this point Brenda decides
she gets
um the 22 that her dad had given her for
Christmas
um you know which had only been like a
month before it's a pistol or a rifle
it's a rifle okay and
um she either now I've heard that she
shot from her bedroom window or that she
busted out the glass in the front door
and shot for the front door it doesn't
really matter but she essentially just
set up kind of like a little command
post there and just started shooting set
up a little sniper position started
shooting at the elementary school from
her house
and just
spray and bullets everywhere now the
thing about Brenda Spencer was that she
was actually she'd been hunting and
target shooting and stuff with her dad
since she was a little kid
um and her dad's friend said she was
like a crack shot so she was like an
expert Marksman better than him he said
girls are good
um girls and girls are real good when
you teach them so uh so yeah so she was
like a really good shot which is
unfortunate in this situation
but she just started shooting
now obviously this was not a thing that
happened all the time so nobody really
knew what was going on at first everyone
just kind of heard noises they thought
it was firecrackers like they somebody
saw one little girl fall down but they
didn't really think anything about it
there was that kind of thing yeah for
any of you people who uh didn't grow up
around guns maybe you're in other
countries 22 long rifles what they're
talking about it's a it's a very
entry-level
sporting trainer
type caliber it's glorified BB gun it'll
kill you
but really it's there are pellet rifles
that have
ballistics similar to that
it's a very small bullet not moving very
fast
out of an eight to 16 inch barrel or
longer it can get pretty fast
in terms of velocity
and um the hitch in the right spot it'll
kill you
it'll kill you dirt and [__] A lot of
people were killed with them over the
years in the United States because there
were so many of them out there
uh not particularly deadly but
everything's about shot placement
pretty so you know
so just let me let you know and here
what they're talking about the
firecracker thing out of a rifle length
barrel they're not very loud
they're they produce less decibels than
your average suppressed or silenced
pistol
a lot of people think silencers make
weapons Silent they don't it just
suppresses it it'll make a subsonic nine
millimeter pistol
sound a little bit louder than a 22 long
rifle that isn't suppressed just makes
everything a lot tame or you don't need
air protection
so yeah from a distance
you'd have a hard time
knowing whether that you were being shot
at you see something happened to
somebody in front of you what the hell
[__] happened he didn't know what
exactly what you were looking at
you may not realize that that person had
been shot well yeah no one really made
the association yeah like they were just
hearing noises they couldn't tell where
they were coming from from a distance
they sound fake cheap
yeah they couldn't tell where they were
coming from and like I said they just
saw a little girl fall and they just
thought oh she fell over they didn't
really it was so like people were so
clueless that you know people were still
like parents were still pulling up to
school like dropping the kids off like
nobody knew what was going on you know
and there was even one thing where I
think one of the bullets hit the fire
alarm and made the fire alarm start
going off yeah so some of the kids that
were already inside like the teachers
like oh fire drill and took the kids
back outside like not knowing that there
was like [__] that they were like in
the firing range
yeah so I can see so it's complete chaos
yeah
um Special Operations uses suppressed
Weaponry a lot because it does confuse
the targets they're not really sure
exactly what's happened it takes a while
to realize that they're being shot at
it's not like a high powered rifle
high-powered rifle a person is piece of
a person is vaporized right in front of
you and then you hear Boom the shot
because the bullet arrives before the
[__] sound of the discharge gets
there because it's ultrasonic
and two you know but it's still it's
like a damn Thunderbolt you know you've
been shot at
but now the 22.
it would take you a little while yeah
it's not that violent in the [__] the
sounds of the shot sound cheap like
cheap firecrackers
they don't sound serious that's what
everybody that was there that they
interviewed for that said that like like
I said and it's not like you're
expecting [__] like this especially back
in 1979 maybe people would be expecting
it nowadays but like back then this had
really never happened like this before
so nobody was
ready for this or they're just kind of
like no so nobody knew it was going on
it was just like complete because there
was kids all in the front of the school
because it was you know it was the start
of the school day and everybody's
getting dropped off and getting off of
buses and [__] like that 22 long rifle
rifles
if you have a long not long enough
Barrel it's burned up so much the powder
that by the time the the bullet leaves
the barrel there's not a lot of
expanding gases left
um now there will be some and there are
ways to suppress that very easily I'm
not going to tell you how that there's
very easy ways
um
with [__] [__] you can find inside
your house
to collect that burning gas and head she
had that on the end
sound would be if it's a bolt action
rifle the sound would be
as quiet as a pellet rifle in other
words impact of the bullet would be
louder
than the discharge of the bullet so the
person screaming after they've been hit
would be the loudest thing
yeah
if you know what you're doing you can do
a lot of damage
well she did yeah
so uh so like I said she's just shooting
um she wasn't shooting randomly she did
seem to be
aiming and hitting what she aimed at
she did hit several children uh one in
the abdomen
one in the side uh one in the shoulder
one in the wrist like the bullet went
all the way through the little girl's
wrist
um so eight children ended up being shot
thankfully none of the children died of
their injuries
um but eight of them were shot
however
two uh three adults were hit and two of
them did die uh two of them at the scene
what ended up happening was that she's
shooting at the kids and the principal
um you know Burton rag who was there who
had just open the gate like to let the
kids in he kind of realized what was
happening and he quite heroically
um was like trying to pull kids out of
the way like to get them to safety he's
like you know duck somebody's shooting
um and he figured it out and um at that
point Brenda shot him directly in the
heart like right in the chest yeah um
and he just uh and he just fell and he
was as far as I know he was killed
instantly yeah Hearts don't work when
they have a little hole in them uh yeah
duh
usually uh
Moon ballistics on a 22 long rifle kind
of look like an ice pick wound it's just
clean in clean out
but if it hits anything that's real
vital like an artery a heart
something deep in the central nervous
system did it kill you
well yeah because somebody that um I was
watching an interview with somebody that
was there that day like another
um somebody that worked at the school
and they said they saw the principal get
hit and they just like all of a sudden
his chest just like just like a thing of
blood and he just like fell yeah well
it's under pressure it's pumping right
so yeah so like I said as far as I know
he was killed instantly yeah the other
person that died was
um the custodian
uh his name was Mike sukar now from what
I've heard of him he was actually um a
Korean War veteran
so he kind of figured out what was going
on too and he also like ran in there
trying to save the kids like trying to
get them out of the way and he was also
trying to go and see if the principal
Burton ragasy saw him fall so he ran
over there to make sure he was all right
like he was gonna help him out
and uh while he was doing that he also
got shot and as far as I know he was
killed at the scene also now the third
adult that got hit was actually not
until a little bit later that was like
one of the cops that showed up um he got
shot too but he actually survived
um which we'll get into in a little bit
because what ended up happening is that
you had like this shooting went on for
about half an hour she was shooting at
the school yeah they weren't sure where
it was coming from yeah they didn't know
where it was coming from at first so you
know and by the time they figured out
what was going on and they were just
kind of like holy [__] like you know the
principal they saw him found and they
see his legs like sticking out of the
Bush and like he's all like you know
covered with blood and she thought she
was gonna get away with it I don't know
about that though but uh no I don't I
don't think she did
but um but yeah so by the time they kind
of figured it out and then they were
just starting like you know wrangling
the kids up and like trying to get them
into the auditorium and like trying to
get the ambulance in there so you could
get the wounded ones out and like they
you know she was still shooting at them
at this point and so they didn't really
and like I said at first they didn't
really know where it was coming from so
it's just a little bit of opportunity
it was a place she could shoot it was a
place she could hit from her house yeah
and I mean I well we'll yeah we'll get
into that a little bit well like I said
this is why I didn't necessarily want to
cover the shooting first because there's
like a lot of details but I'll have to
go back and like backtrack and like talk
about that all right but um so yeah so
what ends up happening is that while the
shooting is going on like while it's
active
um the editors at I believe it was the
San Diego
um Union Tribune I think is the name of
the newspaper there and he so he was
basically like telling his reporters why
don't you like just randomly call people
on that street and see if you can get a
scoop like see what the [__] is going on
down there you know what I mean um and
see if you can get a story
so they start calling phone numbers on
the street like where the school is they
start calling numbers of the house
and it so happened that one of the
reporters called Brenda's house
and she answered the phone
And the reporter and he said she sounded
completely normal like it was just like
a complete like hello like what you know
and um he's like hey you know do you can
you see the shooting from your house or
do you see like what's going on and
she's like she's like yeah I can see the
whole thing and then he said she started
like giggling right and then he's like
well you know what's going on with that
and everything or do you know where the
shots are coming from or something like
that and she's like yeah I know all
about it it's like and then she said
something like yeah it's me that's doing
it and then she hung up yeah I mean and
like I said I was listening to Once Upon
a Crime and she said the girl said like
all kind of crazy because the reporters
kept calling her back being like what
the [__] and like they kept calling her
back and she just kept saying [__] like
um
uh they asked her was like well why are
you doing this like what what are your
reasons for doing this and very famously
she said oh I Don't Like Mondays this
livens up the day she said that was like
her very famous quote
um and then she's saying stuff like it's
like well nobody likes Mondays do you
you know what I mean like this is gonna
be like that's the reason she did it and
then she was talking about that she just
didn't have a reason that she was just
doing it for fun
um that she just wanted to
um she also said something about like
she wanted to shoot cops uh that too
so she was basically just doing it for
shits and giggles and they said that it
was really creepy because she sounded
just like completely
cool and collected and like she just did
not give a single [__] and this was
while the thing was going on like they
were talking to her on the phone and
she's just like yeah I Don't Like
Mondays like that
like she was just totally [__]
callous about it she's crazy
so obviously the reporters are like well
holy [__] it said like they call the
cops
um because like I said I think at this
point like some cops had got there like
the the
um other adult that got injured
um was one of the cops that showed up
because he kind of showed up and was um
kind of trying to you know get it like
corral everybody and he got shot in the
neck I think what ended up happening was
that the bullet hit his
bulletproof vest but it ricocheted and
went into his neck yeah but he lived
like he didn't die but yeah so he got
might have been wounded as well kind of
like a suicide type situation but uh it
was like a failed suicide she's gonna
kill everybody and take everybody with
her you know she's gonna kill herself
and take everybody with her type of deal
but it didn't turn out but I don't know
I'm trying to figure out why somebody
would do this well yeah I still don't
know with this with this Cavalier
attitude makes you think she didn't
expect to survive it
she's trolling him on the phone over it
and trying to take credit
that's what it sounds like I'm thinking
that it's kind of like
I think she
expects to kill herself maybe she
chickened out
yeah it could be I mean at one of like
much later
at one of her parole hearings because
like I said she's had several parole
hearings she's still in there they're
not letting her out but um at one of her
parole hearings she comes up with like
different [__] like every time and I
think at one of the parole hearings she
did say something to the effect of
um I was just hoping that the cops would
turn up and kill me yeah but the thing
about it is is that I don't really know
if you can trust anything she says
because every time she has a parole
hearing she comes up with a different
story yeah you know what I'm saying it
may not be on purpose and maybe that
she's just real uh incoherent
yeah I did kind of get that impression I
mean the thing about it she doesn't seem
like a dumb person and actually
everything like everybody that knew her
like her family and teachers and you
know the few friends that she had prior
to this incident all said that you know
she wasn't a great student but she was
actually like quite intelligent and she
was like quite creative and things like
that but
um so I but I don't think she had much
insight into
what made her do this she's young dumb
probably [__] up hormones like you
mentioned that and uh some kind of
glitchy personality and
got depressed wanted to kill herself but
she couldn't go through with it so she
killed other people
she's probably
hoping that they would come kill her but
they didn't it was something like that
and she can't admit it to herself
something something like that well yeah
I might be able to glean more out of it
yeah I mean once we get more into her
and like once we get more into her
background and stuff like that
so um so like I said the shooting itself
went on for about 30 minutes and like I
said two deaths um and eight wounded
um and the two deaths were adults it was
the principal and the custodian like of
the school
after that like apparently when she was
talking to the reporters on the phone
she basically said something like well I
gotta go like I still have more fun to
have like I want to go shoot some more
people maybe I can get another cop or
something like that because she had
actually hit one of the cops but she
didn't kill him
um so you know allegedly she said that
like over the phone and then she hung up
but after that happened she actually
didn't shoot anymore however she did
barricade herself in her house for about
six hours and would not come out the
reason
um how they got her to stop shooting was
they actually like the cops and stuff
when they showed up they actually
commandeered a garbage truck and pulled
it in front of the school so she
couldn't shoot at the front of the
school anymore and after she didn't have
that you know soft target like the easy
target she kind of just stopped shooting
and just holed up in her house and she
basically said because they had like you
know negotiators there like talking to
her trying to get her to come out and
like trying to get her to surrender and
stuff and she was basically saying well
um if she comes out she's gonna come out
shooting and she was saying all that
kind of stuff I think that she was
living out
I got the impression that she was kind
of living out like her badass like
Bonnie and Clyde fantasy it seemed like
because I feel like she was the kind of
person and I'll get into this in a
little bit too but she seemed like the
kind of person that she wanted very much
to be seen like a badass
um you know what I mean and she kind of
had all these fantasies about
uh you know killing cops and being
famous and all this other kind of [__]
so
I think maybe so some of the stuff she
says like I said you can't really
believe it because she might have been
like really self-aggrandizing yeah well
just some 16 year old girl fantasizing
about that that [__] crazy yeah I mean
like I said that's not I mean just for
the record that's not something that
normal 16 year old girls really
fantasize about I didn't know anybody
that that [__] crazy thought anything
like that I mean
I mean I get I mean actually let me put
some ice in that yeah all my ice melt
Yeah the more normal 16 year old girl
badass fantasies that she's gonna be a
porn star or a stripper well I don't
know about I never thought that no but
some of them do well some of them do but
Tracy Lords well I know that your
stripper I know that but yeah she's like
that's what she did I think that's
unusual too yeah for 16 year olds I
think that's I think you're just
projecting well yeah there's there's
more of those than there are like people
that fan that fantasize about gunning
people down for Christ's sake like I
said it's not very common for
girls say I don't know most girls just
don't
think that way like it doesn't occur to
them
um you know what I mean so I mean unless
they're really really bullied or picked
on or something like that it that then
they might have like fantasies about
like revenge and stuff but it's very
very unusual like this kind of stuff is
very unusual I think that's why I I
found I find this
case so fascinating especially because
like I said nobody really has any idea
she doesn't have any idea why she did it
and you know like I think murder Hornet
was saying somebody said
earlier that it's like sometimes there
isn't a reason and obviously she doesn't
know what the reason is so I mean
and all these years she's had to think
about it I don't think that she has any
further insight into that
so um so yeah
so she's in there for about six seven
hours something like that she's like
holed up in the house or trying to get
her come out like I said she keeps
threatening she's gonna like you know
you get close to the house you know I'm
gonna shoot you too like I've shot all
these people blah blah blah
so they were kind of holding off for a
while but then finally they were able to
coax her into surrendering by because
they were like well you know what can we
do for you or can we bring you something
all she wanted was a Whopper from Burger
King and I was like
man that's all you want like you could
have got something a lot better than
that I would think but you know I mean I
mean admittedly Burger King Whoppers are
probably a lot better in 1979 than they
are now maybe but yeah Whoppers were
good
so was [__] Jumbo Jacks if you guys
remember how good a Jumbo Jack used to
be but that's kind of how they so
basically she said yes she wanted a
Whopper from Burger King and they're
like okay well tell you what we'll give
you a Whopper from Burger King if you
surrender and if you come out the damn
house and bring all bring all the guns
and bring all the ammo bring everything
out here and surrender peacefully and
you can have a [__] Whopper I don't
know if they ever got her a Whopper now
that I'm thinking about it I guess I
imagine yeah John Terminator fantasy is
more of a boy thing yeah that's what I
mean it's I think it's a lot more common
which this is alarming too but it's a
lot more common for boys it's like like
I said girls and you know I don't want
to say like across the board because
yeah like I'm sure some girls have
fantasies like violent fantasies and
stuff but I'm just saying that being a
girl myself and associating with a lot
of girls when I was growing up it's just
not something that ever came up or that
yeah really it's just you don't really
think that way it's just not really
something that occurs to you based on my
studies if if girl has any social
fantasies it's about being naughty
it's not about being Terminator
[__] yeah that really never they're
not being terminated just okay like I
told you the Tracy Lords all right uh
what's his name Angela White who's a big
porn star she said that she wanted to be
a porn star since she was like 16 17.
that she thought that was badass that's
an anti-social fantasy yeah you know
what I mean but it's female
it's not I'm gonna be the Terminator to
[__] shoot up the police station
that's just yeah
that literally never occur that just
doesn't occur to little girls yeah I'm
not really sure what my I think my
fantasy when I was growing up was I
wanted to be like um I wanted to be like
Stephen King yeah I wanted to be like a
famous horror writer that's what I
wanted yeah which isn't necessarily
badass but yeah I didn't really
fantasize about being a badass that
really wasn't something that occurred to
me or was important to me in any way you
know what I mean yeah like I was more
like
I wanna I wanna write horror and be as
rich as Stephen King
that was more what I was like shooting
for it's unusual for even any social
girls to have violent
it is like I said it's just not it's
usually something though that you think
of no it's just not it's hard to explain
maybe to a dude because I guess dudes
like have more violent fantasies than
women do but well the testosterone [__]
and they're just Rough and Tumble played
but you just don't think about it yeah
girls don't think about that they might
fantasize about having a [__]
criminal boyfriend or something who's
nice to them but I don't I don't yeah
and I don't even think that's
necessarily anything to do with their
criminal Behavior per se it's just that
oh he's such a he's such a bad person
but he's nice to me yeah yeah yeah like
I'm special so it's more like an I'm
special fantasy than it is like oh I'm
dating a criminal fantasy because you
know in when the rubber hits the road
you don't really want to be dating a
criminal it's like that never ends well
but um I'm just saying that usually
that's
that's a Beauty and the Beast fantasy as
well like the serial killer groupies
yeah damn [__] it's not like I said if
they were actually there and like saw
this a serial killer like you know
cutting off some with like Ted Bundy
like cutting off someone's head and like
using it for a sex toy
um I think their order would cool pretty
quickly if they were actually there and
witnessed that actually happening in
front of them like I don't think they
would think it was so cool I would hope
not unless they were [__] psychotic
too yeah well actually we're getting off
topic way off topic but somebody was
psychoanalyzing the damn
um the serial killer groupies and they
said no them [__] are crazy too
they're crazy oh I don't doubt it yeah
that there's some kind of a crazy glitch
in a certain type of women that they
have to be with some dude who's a
[__] killer and and
the weirder he is the more they like him
and that that woman that married Ted
Bundy and was in the [__] courtroom
with him she just happened to have yeah
she's a whack job and she [__] fell
for the dude and she knew he was a
necrophile and killed little girls and
[__] like that and that was just that
was just even more enticing because that
is just not normal I mean look I'm I'm a
horror nerd I love horror [__] I love
talking about serial killers and stuff I
don't want to hang out with serial
killers I don't want to date a serial
killer [__] that a lot of those serial
killers have orbital girlfriends that
help them select victims and are there
that's [__] watching him kill the
woman they're just those [__] is just
crazy they're just as crazy as him it's
just a different kind of crazy it's a
different error but they they find each
other somehow through I guess natural
selection because if she wasn't like
that he'd killed her yeah you know what
I mean so she's alive because she was
like that yeah
yeah Camp Guy saying everybody look at
me
yeah see I was I'm like the opposite I'm
just when I was a kid I was like
everybody please don't look at me maybe
that's why I didn't have any of that
kind of well the naughty girl fantasies
you know is look at me yeah look at me
see I didn't really I don't really like
being
looked at necessarily in that way so
it's just kind of like and I especially
did it back then yeah so that's probably
why I didn't have any fantasies in that
regard uh thank you very much John
Robertson who gave us a Super Chat and
also I have to mention now that you are
here uh I would like to thank you again
John Robertson because you are our
newest Patron oh yeah that's right
that's right became the patron I think I
mentioned it on the last show like when
you actually said that but I like to
mention on the main show too so you know
so it doesn't get lost on the shuffle uh
but yeah he says Hey guys wanted to
contribute to the flash bulbs speaking
of horror novels Jenny I'm in the
process of writing a novel like whatever
happened to Baby Jane but with guys ooh
all right that sounds fantastic actually
yeah when you finish it like send me and
I'll I'll read it because that that
sounds intriguing that was a good movie
I actually love that movie yeah but uh
yeah that's a great book it's cool
she'll review it yeah if it's not good
she's not gonna review it because it'll
[__] you up she'll say oh this movie
this book sucks no well I've had that
happen a few times where like I was
contacted by an author and they were
like um you know hey I'll send you a
book if you review it and I'm just like
sure you know because I'm a nice person
and I read it I'm like oh man this is
really not good what am I gonna say and
then I was like I always have to be like
super super like diplomatic yeah about
it well I mean some of the ones that
I've gotten were actually like really
really good so I didn't have to yeah be
that way so the ones that weren't any
good did you do the review yeah you did
the review anyway but you were
diplomatic about the review yeah yeah
okay because it's like here I'm a writer
too yeah so it's just kind of like I
know
um you know it sucks like having
somebody like [__] on something that
you've spent months and years of your
life working on yeah so it's like I'm
really hesitant to like do that to
somebody else but then on the other hand
I was like well I try to be like
um constructive yeah I think a lot of
the problems
um usually boil down to they just need
an editor because you know their grammar
is not good or something like that like
a lot of it's that kind of stuff which
can be fixed yeah what I mean okay so
it's not it's not usually a story it's
usually just great not not necessarily
it's usually [__] like that but to be
honest
um if you're gonna be a writer you
really really need to master grammar and
spelling I mean I I would advise
because otherwise you're gonna have
[__] like me reading it going Jesus
Christ man they were saying where did
you go to school they were saying on
that event horizon
show that that new AI [__] super
computer they have can write [__] any
kind of book they say it's awesome
and then they could write movie scripts
better than a Hollywood movie
and you'd give it the parameters of what
you want the story to be like and it'll
it'll write a [__] say it'll write
four or five different versions of that
story if you don't like a thing it'll go
okay then I'll change yeah you can fix
that you can fix it yeah they say they
say that that [__] is going to put
writers in Hollywood out of business
that it just that's how good it writes
yeah I'd like to read some of that [__]
Ben says speaking of which I need your
postal address to send you something can
you advise I emailed you
um yeah well if you emailed me unless it
went in my junk folder then um then I'll
send you the postal address like if I
see the email if not then I mean you can
uh message me on Facebook or Facebook
will probably be the best that probably
be the most likely that I would see it
but uh Instagram works too
so just go to the 13 o'clock page and
send me a message on there and I will
probably see it
um you know because I haven't seen the
email today but like I haven't checked
it for several hours so I don't really
know
um so yeah so let's see where was I
um okay so she's in there for six seven
hours finally there she's like hey I
want a Whopper and they're like okay
well you can have one if you come out
so she actually came out and like
surrendered peacefully brought out uh
her guns uh and laid them down on the
ground like along with all the ammo that
she had
and they took her into custody
apparently allegedly
um she was very interested she was kind
of like well is this going to be on T
like is this on TV and they're like yeah
there's TV you know Crews and stuff all
around here and she's like are you gonna
put handcuffs on me like she seemed very
interested she really wanted them
I guess she really wanted to be seen on
TV with handcuffs on
so like I said she seemed to have like a
weird fantasy about
I think she said too one of the things
she said to the reporters over the phone
was something like my dad is gonna flip
out
like that was one of the things that she
said so
I guess I mean she for real did this for
attention I mean I that's for sure but I
don't know it was kind of a messed up
way to get attention I mean can't you
just get a tattoo or like a weird
piercing or something like that come on
but um just
just don't don't shoot innocent people
just Pro tip so uh so yeah
now apparently now here's where some
sources differ too because I've seen I
feel like there's been some details of
this case that have been
um changed or uh not changed necessarily
but embellished like in some tellings of
the story because some tellings of the
story
say that when the police went into the
house like to gather up the rest of the
stuff they said it was kind of like not
necessarily squalor but it was kind of
like in disarray I guess and they said
there was like empty
um
whiskey bottles and like empty beer
bottles around the house
um and one of the things that Brenda
Spencer would later claim at one of her
many parole hearings was that oh I was
so [__] up on drugs and alcohol at the
time the shooting that I don't even
remember what happened however
um as they would usually do after they
arrested her they did a Toxicology test
and they found zero trace of drugs or
alcohol in her system so she was just
making that up now one thing that I did
hear they said another source that I saw
said there actually wasn't liquor
bottles like empty liquor bottles all
over the house but there was like a a
bottle of I believe it was whiskey that
was like right near the door where she'd
been shooting from and it was only about
a quarter full
um but since they didn't find any
alcohol in her blood like when they did
the toxicology after they took her into
custody
um it wasn't her that was drinking it
and they're not real clear about where
it came from because I think her dad had
been an alcoholic but I think that he
was on the wagon so I don't think that
he actually allowed alcohol in the house
so she might have got it somewhere else
but like I said because they did the
toxicology and they didn't find
any alcohol in her system then it wasn't
her that was drinking it so I don't
really know where it came from
so yeah so they took her into custody
like I said completely peacefully now
even though she was only 16 years old
because of the severity of the crime
obviously they decided pretty much
immediately that they were going to try
her as an adult now what they actually
said was that they're like okay well you
can do a plea deal they're like if you
plead guilty to the two murder charges
then
um will give you then maybe you'll get
like 25 to life with the possibility of
parole they're like on the other hand if
you plead not guilty and it ends up
going to trial
um it might then we might end up
charging you like not only with two
murders but also I think they charge you
with two murders and also like assault
with a deadly weapon
but they said then we also charge you
with the eight additional charges of
like you know attempted murder because
you know the eight people that were
wounded
um you know and then there's a chance
that you know you might get life without
parole
so her uh attorney advised her to take
the plea deal so that's essentially what
she did like she didn't go to trial they
didn't send her to juvie
um she stayed in juvie like while they
were going through all the legal
wrangling and stuff like that but in the
end she actually did plead guilty to the
two murders and assault with the deadly
weapon charges and they just gave her 25
to life with the possibility of parole
now her first parole hearing was
actually in 1993 and she's had ones I
think every four years since then but
every single time like it's always been
denied and I think the last one was in
2022 and that one was denied also like I
said I don't think they're ever going to
let her out and I think it's mainly well
it's for various reasons but I think
it's mainly because she doesn't even
though she does Express remorse for what
she did and she seems to feel bad that
she's like oh and now every time she
hears about a school shooting nowadays
she always always wonders like oh did
they get the idea from me
um and she like because she was kind of
like the first one you know what I mean
but
because she keeps coming up with other
excuses and like other reasons like
every single time
um they're just concerned that she
hasn't really learned anything or she
hasn't really really like owned what she
did you know what I mean like taking
responsibility for him
so let's talk about
this girl
so
she was um like I said she was 16 years
old in 1979 and she had lived in a
suburb of San Diego which is called San
Carlos and I believe she lived there her
entire life
now the house that she lived in across
from Grover Cleveland
um she lived there with her parents now
she had an older sister who I think her
name was Teresa
um Teresa was off at College when the
when this incident occurred she also had
an older brother I believe whose name
was Scott
and he was kind of a little bit of a
troublemaker too not bad bad but kind of
you know because like the druggie and
stuff like that
um and at the time of this incident he
was like just off kind of like wandering
around the country you know what I mean
so he wasn't like living in the house
and I don't think her and her brother
were kind of close but her and her
sister not so much so she was like kind
of an isolated kid like I said she was
very small uh she's only five foot two
very very skinny like back then I'm not
anymore uh but yeah she had like really
really long like red hair and very very
tomboyish very quiet kind of bookish
um you know not she had a couple of
friends but she wasn't obviously like
rolled super popular or anything like
that
now a lot of her teachers said that she
was actually very intelligent um even
though she didn't really seem to give
much of a [__] about school and was kind
of like falling asleep in class and not
really paying attention but when she
applied herself she seemed to be uh
really good particularly at creative
type stuff poetry she was actually like
a really good photographer she won some
awards for photography uh particularly I
think she really likes animals so she
took like a lot of pictures of animals I
think there were some reports later that
she was kind of one of those wild shows
like oh she was you know abusing animals
and all this other kind of stuff I don't
think that's necessarily true
um there were also some reports too that
she was like this big druggie and this
big alcoholic according to her brother
um he said she wasn't really a drinker
it said she might have smoked some pot
on occasion but you know later on I
think they were trying to make her seem
like more of a monster than she actually
was they were saying oh my God she was
you know doing all the drugs and you
know a drunk and all this other kind of
stuff and he's like that's not really
the case
um like I said maybe she smoked some pot
but it wasn't really that big of a deal
because like I said later on she said oh
on the day of the shooting she's like oh
I just drank all I was drinking whiskey
all day and I was smoking marijuana
laced with PCP and like all this other
kind of stuff I'm like the toxicology
report found nothing there was nothing
in her system no drugs no alcohol no
nothing and then when they confronted
her with that information
um she said oh well the reports must
have been falsified there are two
reports that's what she said like in the
interview well there must be two reports
because I was completely [__] up but
the thing about it is that when they
arrested her like when she surrendered
they're like she did not seem
intoxicated or impaired in any way
whatsoever she was walking normally they
didn't you know she wasn't staggering or
nothing like that she just seemed
completely normal so so there was that
um so her parents divorced when she was
about 10. now her mom's name is Dot and
her dad's name is Wallace or Wally
now the mom says and I've seen like some
interviews with her mom and I don't want
to [__] on her mom too much but I will
say I don't think her mom abused her or
anything like that but I do
her mom did come across as a little
what's a good way of putting it
emotionally detached I don't think that
her and her kids were particularly close
and it seemed like she wasn't
real affectionate it seemed like she
wasn't real proactive in
relating to them
um I don't know it's I don't I wouldn't
go so far as to say like she didn't give
a [__] or she didn't care about them
but she really did seem like when Brenda
was a teenager she kind of like
distanced herself a little bit she was
just like oh well after her and Wallace
got divorced she was just kind of like
oh well I left it up to Brenda like if
she wanted to come see me or not like
she didn't really seem to make an effort
like to maintain a relationship with her
daughter and she didn't really seem to
know what was going on in her life or I
don't know so it really seemed like she
was very detached yeah well that kind of
sounds like some of the families of the
male serial killers it's not open abuse
against him it's just kind of like
neglect the parents don't yeah the
parents don't really seem to care one
way or the other Dahmer's parents were
kind of like that yeah
um where which in a lot of ways is just
as bad I mean it's just like yeah you
know yeah he does what he wants to do
that type of deal and um the other one
[__] uh
what's in the Ted Bundy's parents were
kind of like that
well it turns out his sister was his
parent
and his parents were his grandparents he
didn't know about that yeah but they
were just kind of indifferent
yeah I kind of got the feeling that
that's what was happening here too it's
almost like attention-seeking Behavior
like I said the mom she didn't she
didn't come across to me like I don't
know her okay but it's just like in the
interviews she didn't come across as
like a bad person or anything like that
but she just came across this very like
I said just very detached
um and from everything I've heard she
seemed kind of detached at the time now
so they got divorced I think Brenda was
10.
and according to dot the mom she said it
was because Wallace was [__] around
on her Wallace denies this however there
was a situation this is so weird Wallace
apparently comes to Dot and says would
you still like take me back if I just
like
left for a year or we separated for a
year and like could I come back after
like he didn't want to divorce her like
he still wanted that to fall back on I
guess but he wanted to go like [__]
around and like do whatever he wanted
for a year and Dot was like yeah no
that's that's not happening
so that was kind of when they got
divorced now the weird thing that
happened with this too and this is you
know maybe not as unusual nowadays but
very unusual for 1979 was that when they
got divorced Wallace got custody of the
kids no one's entirely sure why this is
it's not because the mom was abusive or
anything like that because usually that
would be the situation but from
everything that I read it seemed like
what happened
was that the older kids like Brenda's
older siblings Scott and Teresa they
preferred to live with their dad maybe
allegedly because their dad was more was
less um
uh inclined to kind of like fog up on
them and like check what they were doing
like he was more permissive
um that was the speculation anyway and
so because the older kids wanted to go
live with the dad then the judge was
like well I don't want to break up you
know all of the siblings so then Brenda
ended up going and living with the dad
as well
so the mom goes off and lives by herself
and then Brenda would go and visit her
mom every now and then but then like she
started doing it less and less and like
I said her mom didn't really seem
to care all that much like if she came
or not you know what I mean
um at least according to most I mean the
mom actually kind of like denies this
but that was kind of the way it came off
came off to me
so what ends up happening is that so
they move in with the dad
and like I said the older sister she
goes off to college and Scott goes off
wandering around to doing whatever he's
doing because he's a little bit older
too so it's basically just Brandon her
dad living in this house
now her dad as far as I know was an
alcoholic but I think like I said that
he was on the wagon so I don't think he
was drinking anymore now he's dead now
uh he died in 2016. uh he was 84 or
something like that but um I saw an
interview with him and I'm not gonna
like I said I don't know the dude and I
don't know if the allegations that
Brenda later made about him are true but
the dude came off a little weird and I
can't quite put my finger on what was
bothering me about him like I don't know
he just came across as really weird
because it was this documentary that was
made I think it was made in 2006 or 2008
or something like that and this British
crew that were making the documentary
um no one had really interviewed him
like in all this time and they actually
went to the house because like I said he
lived in the same house as far as I know
like until he died like the same house
that she shot from and he lived there
all his life
so they actually went there and at first
he wouldn't come out and like talked to
them but then after a while he's like
okay I'll come out and talk to you but I
have to come out and like we have to
talk in the yard like he wouldn't let
them come inside the house which again I
thought was so I don't know if it wasn't
filthy in there yeah that's what I was
thinking maybe it was filthy in there or
there was some weird [__] going on but
he seemed kind of weird so the thing
about it and they were asking him about
this because this was when this
documentary came out was right around I
think it was 2006 and
um Brenda had just had one of her parole
hearings and at this particular parole
hearing her excuse this time because
like I said her excuse before had been
on I was so [__] up on drugs and
alcohol that I didn't remember that I
didn't know what I was doing and like I
said they were like well obviously
that's a lie because the toxicology
report said you were totally sober so no
parole for you
um but this time around she actually
said that she had been sexually abused
by her father
um for many years and so she was I guess
she was trying to Garner sympathy like I
said I'm not a person that's gonna like
deny people's allegations of sexual
abuse because I know it happens a lot
and that's a shitty thing to do but in
her case I'm not really sure if it's
true that said
um her dad is pretty weird now it is
pretty widely reported
that
um you know and I this might even be on
the Wikipedia page I'm not entirely sure
I don't really remember but it said that
her and her dad
shared a bed or like shared a mattress
like in a room
now I don't think this is the case
they asked the dad about this and he
said oh well we used to share a bedroom
but we had separate beds and I assumed
that he meant because I think the house
has three bedrooms so I assume he meant
that when the other two teenagers were
living there like I'm assuming the older
sister and the older brother had their
own rooms and then there was one bedroom
left so Brenda and her dad were like you
know in beds on opposite sides of the
room which is weird but understandable
because when the cops went in the house
like after the shooting they didn't say
anything about that like so I'm assuming
that Brenda had her own room at that
point because by that point her two
older siblings were gone
um so it was just her and her dad and
like I said I'm pretty sure it was a
three bedroom house
so I think the allegations about her
sharing a bed with her dad are
not true but I think that is like
reported a lot
but I am gonna say here's one weird
thing that maybe maybe
give some credibility to the sexual
abuse allegations
so Wallace divorced you know uh Brenda's
mom Dot
and then like after Brenda was
incarcerated I think this was when she
this might have been when she was still
in juvie because here's the thing she
was in juvie a little bit like before
the shooting incident because it turns
out that she had actually shot at that
same school with a pellet gun like a BB
gun
uh I believe a year before the actual
murder is shooting and she like stolen
some [__] from there too like she'd
broken into the school and shot the
windows out and stuff like nobody was
there at the time
but she had done that and so she was on
probation for that
so I don't know if it was during this
time period if it was after the shooting
but her dad would come and visit her at
in jail like at juvie or whatever
and her cellmate at the time was this
girl I think her name was Sheila and
Sheila was also a minor she was 17.
when Sheila got out
um
Brenda's dad who was at that time about
40 or 41 years old
um started a sexual relationship with
Sheila who was 17.
got her pregnant
and she had the baby and then he married
her
so
Brenda's new stepmom
was essentially like the same age as her
or like yeah or like a year younger than
her hmm
um and another weird thing is that not
too long yeah or something like that
yeah or the same age or something like
that because that was like her cell mate
like a jubi yeah
and so like after the baby was born
Sheila [__] off
and left the baby with Wallace and
Wallace raised the kid okay
it was just like a weird and a lot of
people too I don't know if this is
entirely true because I've never seen
Sheila but a lot of several sources said
that Sheila looked almost exactly like
Brenda hmm
um so much so that when Sheila moved
into the house like after she married
Wallace some people thought that Brenda
had been LED out of prison and were like
calling the police being like what the
[__] is Brenda doing out they're like
what are you talking about Brenda's not
out that's how much this girl like
supposedly looked like her so that gives
me a little bit of pause that maybe
she's not making up the sexual abuse
stuff because that is
pretty weird that's pretty weird for
your dad to marry a girl that is the
same age as your daughter and looks just
like your daughter okay that's it's not
illegal
it's just
but you know it's just questionable
that's all it's weird so I'm just saying
that that's why I don't completely
discount the sexual abuse stuff even
though I will say that I listened to
part of the parole hearing where she
made it 40 41 something like that and he
got a 17 year old wife yeah
who is his daughter's cell mate that's
how he met her that's how he met her
yeah like when when he went to visit
Brenda
yeah see that's what I said I was like
like I said not illegal
technically
but you know not that in a way okay it's
not like he went out and hunted one down
that looked like his daughter she looked
like his daughter by just by pure chance
she just happened to be the the
daughter's cell mate
by this by the laws of that state she
wasn't underage but that shit's [__]
untactful
quite a bit a little that's that's a
good way of putting it very untactful
um weird yeah it is a little uh given
the dude some side eye yeah type of
thing
you don't go after your daughter's
friends
yeah I mean if you can get it you don't
do it I mean I don't have a dog that's a
party
yeah because that's [__] creepy
that's why like I said it's not illegal
it's just [__] creepy yeah it's
creepy
30 year old guy and a [__] 17 year
old girl
not a whole lot in common there's a huge
generation cap there
you know what I mean
yeah now you know
early 50s early 30s I can understand
that that's that's pretty common
but when you start moving the age back
to the [__] late that's what I mean
like the older the people get like the
less weird it is right obviously but
it's like yeah but when you have like 40
50 year old dudes and like a teenager
yeah that's different or even somebody
in their early 20s then you're kind of
like yeah yeah like I said it's not
illegal it's just a lot of guys second
wives it's just weird a lot of guys
second wives when they're late 40s early
30s the second wife's in her 30s you
know or you know late 40s early 50s the
second wife say this 30s That's Not
Unusual yeah that's and that's not
that's weird I mean that's still like a
mature because it's an adult woman not
still an adult yeah like I said it's not
just trying to get a teenager or a
college student yeah she's available and
she's trying to get married probably
doesn't have any kids looking for a kid
that kind of stuff you know what I mean
it's a clock ticket
so you know that's a lot more
understandable but a 40 year old a 17
year old
that's some side and especially like his
daughters because when I I like I got
out of the army at [__] like 25 I
wouldn't date a 17 or older 25.
you know like I'm like nah yeah and it's
like even that's not like a huge gap
like that's a high school but still yeah
yeah and I mean club girl you know what
I mean [__] that kind of [__] you
know right yeah I mean [__] they can't
even drink well not legally anyway yeah
what fun are they they're still in
school man right it's just take her to
the club you can't get any street cred
off that
I mean I just kind of feel like I mean
how much about the college and forget
about your ass anyway right how much of
a loser would like a 25 year old guy
it's like oh I gotta pick up my
girlfriend at a high school high school
yeah like
you gotta pick her up from her [__]
she's got she's got chorus practice my
friends would never would have let me
live that down that's what I mean it
just seems like like I said that just
seems like yeah [__] I don't know
1920 maybe 17 no like I said still in
high school yeah it's High School 19's
out of high school yeah you're at a high
school yeah so usually in college by
then right
because uh in
when I was in the Army in Boston they
could get in they could get in and they
could get into nightclubs at 18. they
couldn't drink until they're 21 though
so you had them in there yeah I mean
that's the same here you can get in at
18 but they put like an x on your hand
you just can't drink right that's all
all there's some clubs around here have
gone to 21 plus just because they've
been getting in trouble yeah because
people have been the bartenders are
flipping the 18 year olds yeah right not
see not even so much the bartenders but
like other people you know what I mean
like they're they'll bring older friends
like I gotta admit I've done it yeah I
think everyone's done it yeah they're
like [__] remember uh
Aaliyah and [__] what was his name
[__] uh Nick yeah Nick's in the club
he's a [__] full-grown man to me it's
like a guy I'd be in the army with here
man if I could take that [__] and then a
couple weeks later he was 21. he's 21
now 21 now yeah it was only like a few
weeks like a few weeks
he was only a few weeks under 20. yeah
that dude was getting high and tripping
balls before he was in the club anyway
that's true he's showing up the club
High yeah man have a drink
you're all right yeah
but yeah so so whether or not I don't
know so like I said at this particular
parole hearing
um I guess maybe it was like earlier
than I'm thinking it was maybe it was in
2001 that she said this but um but she
did come out but the fact that she never
said this
she never accused her dad of sexual
abuse before and her other siblings
um as much as they I don't really think
that the other siblings talk all that
much about it but I mean understandably
they just don't want anything to do with
this [__] because they weren't that
close to their sister I guess
um so they said you know that no none of
that was going on
and um you know and I don't even think
the mom
thought any of that was going on either
so I don't know how true it is but like
I said it is very very weird that the
dad married someone that was the same
age and the same appearance as his
daughter I mean that's a little
like I said it just makes me kind of
like raise my eyebrows a little bit is
all I'm saying
um so there's that
now uh also too like the documentary I
was watching where they actually
interviewed this dude like in his yard
like I said the yard across from the
school where the shooting took place
um he seemed very surprised that because
the documentary crew had just come from
the parole hearing like they'd filmed it
and so they said do you know that at the
parole hearing your daughter said that
you know you sexually abused her blah
blah and he seemed shocked by that by
that what what she said that when did
she say that you know what I mean but I
don't know like I said I can't really
put my finger on what bothered me about
him though because he came across as
man I don't know he didn't seem drunk
but there was something that mattered
with him in 95 though right no no not in
this this was like 2001 or something
like that so this was he was still you
know not young young but he was like you
know much younger than 85. he was 85
when he died he was just hiding
something he was probably in his 60s I
imagine he was hiding something yeah he
just came across as like kind of weird
and like creepy to me and I mean like he
was only married to the 17 year old for
however long the pregnancy you know nine
months obviously or something like that
because after the baby was born
apparently the girl was like yeah I'm
out she split I don't know she split and
left the baby there whatever happened to
her I'm not real sure she belongs to the
streets I don't know and I don't know
what happened to the kid either I mean I
think I I mean obviously they'd be an
adult now but I think the kid turned out
all right but right but I don't know it
was like maybe the kid went to her
parents yeah maybe yeah I'm not really
sure but yeah that was just like a whole
[__] weird situation all around
um so I don't know like I said the
family Dynamic there just seemed real
I mean the thing about it was that
Brenda and her dad they seemed like
he didn't really seem all that into or
interested in what she was doing another
thing too when going back to her mom
because remember how I was saying how
her mom was like super detached and
everything yeah this is some crazy [__]
too
when the authorities called Dot
called her mom
to tell her
um hey have you heard about the shooting
at Cleveland Elementary we're pretty
sure like your daughter is the main
suspect
um you know you need to get down here
all dot said was oh well I'm at work and
I can't leave right now that's like all
she said like she didn't even really
give a [__] like oh my God my daughter
is in trouble or anything like which a
normal person would do like I need to
get down there right away she's like oh
well she worked at a golf course I think
like do and she was like oh well I have
all this money and I can't leave it and
blah blah and the cops were like um you
need to get down here like right now
okay you know what I mean so the fact
that she was just kind of like oh that's
all she cared about was work even though
her daughter had just been accused of
murder maybe it didn't really strike
maybe maybe hit her with the reality of
it maybe she couldn't process it maybe
but it did seem kind of I've Been Told
things just out of the blue and it took
me a while to process what I was being
told yeah that's true it might have been
it that's true
but um but yeah so like I said so she
grew up with her dad and her and her dad
were apparently pretty close but more
like buddy buddy close not really like
where she could tell him anything
um you know about her feelings or
whatever
um you know they would go out target
shooting and all this other kind of
stuff now she also kind of had trouble
in school
um like I said she wasn't dumb she was
actually like very intelligent but she
really didn't seem to care much about
school she didn't really like authority
figures
um so she kind of started skipping
school a lot
so they actually sent her to another
school like a special school for you
know truants and like problem children
and stuff like that and while she was
there they did like a psychological
evaluation of her and they determined
that she was suffering from terrible
depression and that she was possibly
suicidal
so they told her um and like I said
around this time too she had shot out
the windows of that same school and like
broke in there and like stole some [__]
and stuff too so she got in trouble for
that
so they had sent her to the special
school and
um essentially they went to her dad and
said um you know they recommended that
she be admitted to a mental hospital for
observation because like I said they
thought that she you know was having
some problems and that maybe she was
gonna do herself some harm
um and her dad at that point said no he
wouldn't give permission for her to be
uh put in the hospital because he's like
well well I can handle that myself
um so a few months after this after this
the you know the people at the school
told her hey we we think she might be
suicidal and she needs some help and her
dad said no I'm gonna take care of it a
few months after that for Christmas of
uh her dad Wallace gave her a Ruger 22
semi-automatic uh 22 caliber rifle for a
Christmas present along with uh a bunch
of ammunition must have been a 10 22.
yeah it was uh had a telescopic site on
it yeah and everything those things have
been around forever
you're a good little rifle just this is
a family rifle
yeah but he gave her that for Christmas
now I've heard okay I've heard two
different stories about this the most
famous story is that
um Brenda actually did not ask for the
gun uh she had actually wanted a radio
and her dad gave her the gun instead
good right because he wanted it I mean
they had gone they had been out like
they did go out target shooting all the
time like you know and they so it wasn't
weird weird that he would give her that
for a present because that was something
that they did together they're not they
weren't that expensive in the time
you're talking about but she did she did
say like on many that's like she hadn't
really asked for one specifically but
then I heard like another source that
said no she really did ask for one and
that she kept bugging him about it and
then he finally bought it so I don't
know if that's the case or not but the
most famous story is that
um she didn't ask for one and that she
got it for Christmas anyway and that she
perceived this as her dad
um suggesting to her that she killed
herself because like I said she was
suicide all and the fact that these
School authorities had told him that and
he had just kind of blown it off
um that apparently kind of made
something of an impression on her I
don't buy that I don't buy this I'm just
saying that's that's what chances are
she wanted a radio he gave her a [__]
rifle because they went out shooting
anyway he probably wanted the rifle too
he says that would be a good compromise
I'll give her something that I want well
in that credit card price but I don't
think it probably had anything to do
with her killing herself that's how a
lot of that's how a lot of people buy
gifts like yeah yeah I think that's what
it was
you know why I always think of that but
every time that happens I always think
of that I don't even remember what year
this came out but that Simpsons episode
where Homer gives Marge a bowling ball
yeah right yeah because it's like that's
what he wants that's what he wanted and
she gets so mad that just despite him
she goes and takes bowling lessons and
then ends up kind of getting romanced by
the bowling instructor okay yeah I don't
know why I remember yeah but it's like I
just thought that was so funny the 1022
was a nice little family
trainer plinker it did a little bit of
everything
light hunting Target just
familiarization training became a lot of
good accessories though they're still
around the day but in the day that
they're talking about they weren't
expensive maybe a hundred dollars
so it's not like he's not reaching too
deep in the pocket for the for the gift
to begin with
it's just it was it was just so he's a
cheapskate as well
it's just this he isn't really going out
of his way to [__] buy something
super expensive it's just entry level
basic real real basic but you know it
probably lived in limited income family
you know
it was just an okay gift
yeah I mean by all accounts they were a
pretty I don't know if it was like
crushing poverty but they weren't
I heard that like the inside of the
house like when they went in there
um I don't think it was as [__]
wrecked as like some later account said
it was like with the whiskey bottles
everywhere and stuff but they did say
that it looked I think they said this
out Once Upon a Crime that it looked
more like a bachelor pad than like a
family house yeah
and I don't know if like Wallace was
[__] around on the wife she said he
was he said he wasn't but she said that
dot the mom she said that when Wallace
came to her and made the proposition hey
would you still wait for me or be here
if I took off for a year and just like
[__] around or did whatever
um you know and she was like [__] that
like no absolutely not
um what she didn't know at the time was
that he'd already like rented an
apartment and like all this other kind
of stuff so you want to move out on his
own for a little while yeah and then and
then wanted her to still be there like
when he got back like like I said they
like to fall back on it you need to take
a break and she's like uh no that's not
how that works he needed to take a break
I guess like I said if you saw the dude
like I said he's dead now he died in
2016 but
I don't know there was just something
really weird about him and I couldn't
like put my finger on what I wanted to
take a year off I guess
now the mom um has gone on record as
saying she blames him but that she
blames him for Brenda doing what she did
because he bought her the gun and and he
also didn't um
you know he wouldn't uh allow her to
receive mental health treatment even
though several uh you know people at the
school and uh things like that like
suggested that she needed it
um they were even going to hospitalize
her like I said because they were
worried about her but he would not allow
it so I got a feeling he's one of those
guys that didn't believe in that kind of
[__] it's like oh there's nothing wrong
with her sure they all agree with uh
yeah I kind of I kind of got that
impression I kind of got that impression
too but oh it's not serious well and
like I said I kind of feel like I mean
this was 1979
um you know
mental health was really not where it is
today uh I feel like nowadays it's
probably taken a lot more seriously like
back then yeah it was just gonna suck it
up you're fine you know what I mean it
was it was still very much like that I
think which that helps no one I'm sorry
I think with this little chick what the
deal was is that she's
high testosterone
got hormonal imbalances
very tomboyish she has a lot of male
features
and she's a [__] psychopath that's
depressed another thing too I forgot to
mention she has boy fantasies the
fantasies that boys have which is you
know fantasies that evil boys have you
know which is yeah I'm gonna be a
criminal like I said very very unusual
for a girl yeah very unusual for a girl
that is I think I think there's going to
be a hormonal fat thing here another
thing too that I forgot to mention was
that a couple of things
one um when they did it when she was in
custody and they did um you know
physical exams and things like that uh
they actually did find that she had some
damage to her temporal lobe yeah there's
that old head injury turns out that she
had had a bicycle accident I believe she
hit a pole yeah when she was younger and
had damaged her temporal lobe wasn't
drastic but maybe um can maybe a
contributing foot enough uh also they
determined that she had a particular
kind of I don't know if it was caused by
the injury or not but um she did have a
particular kind of temporal lobe
epilepsy yeah which um is associated
like generally epilepsy is not
associated with violent outcomes but uh
the particular type of epilepsy I
believe that she was diagnosed with did
one of the effects was a violent
outbursts no boyfriends no interest in
boys
uh she came out later as a lesbian and
she later said that she knew she was a
lesbian from birth
um you know or as soon as she you know
that but I don't you know I I don't know
so that might have been another
contributing factor is that like I said
this is still 1979 and that was
obviously not as acceptable back then so
maybe she was maybe she thought she was
crazy yeah maybe she was like confused
and she didn't really have anybody to
turn to right she wanted to be a boy to
talk to about it
um so that might have been another
contributing factor uh also and this is
strange because like I said I was
listening to Once Upon a Crime and they
mentioned something on there that most
of the other things about Brenda Spencer
don't mention and I don't so I don't
know if this is true or not so take it
with a grain of salt it's very likely
that it's true because the rest of the
podcast it was an hour long and it
seemed very well researched like they
had a lot of details in there but
apparently
um uh Brenda was friends with this boy
named Brent Brent Brent Brent I think it
was Brent and he was actually younger
than her I think he was only 13 or 14.
and according to family members
neighbors things like that um Brenda had
been a perfectly nice girl like you know
all the kids in the neighborhood liked
her and she was just a lovely person
until she started hanging out with this
kid so they're kind of because this kid
they said was was a [__] and
everybody was happy when he moved away
he was a bad influence sorry so yeah so
they said that might have been a
contributing factor too
um the two of them like he would come
over her house and they would watch cop
shows together and they'd be like yeah
we're gonna kill some pigs and all that
kind of stuff so they were getting off
all into these like violent fantasies
and whatnot so that might be another and
like I said a lot of other things about
Brenda Spencer don't bring him up so I
don't really know like the only the
first time I heard about it was on Once
Upon a Crime that she was friends with
this little boy so
no interest in boys
she doesn't have a girlfriend
she's got a little 13 year old boyfriend
who's a bad influence on her
so what you're dealing with sexual
frustration too she's not getting laid
yeah I'm sure that wasn't she's not
getting laid he's not getting laid she
can't get what she wants she's
frustrated
foreign
at the age of 16 is the finder is 16 and
17 year old [__] boy and a girl and
they have a [__] threesome
by the children the [__] I have that old
boy [__] blow her back out and then
[__] she's got the girl there and she
could sort it out she could figure out
what she likes best that's [__] that
defuse all that [__] have her floating
on air for a couple weeks she'd feel a
lot better about herself maybe I would
have diffused a lot of that maybe I mean
that's the thing she seemed to have like
some other problems too but um it's not
like she just needed a good influence in
her life and some good experience but
she's coming out of this [__]
depressing ass home with the [__]
creepy ass dad in a [__] disheveled
old [__] apartment she have a little
house that looks all like a bachelor's
pad there's
no [__] feminine touch to herself or
anything in her environment and her mama
seems kind of like checked out so she
can't really she like I said it's it
seemed like she was going through a time
when yeah that's what's going on she
didn't really have a confusion anybody
to turn to so it just seemed like she
started lashing out like in destructive
way possible should have taken her and
[__] just dolled her up just the
cutest outfit ever just lipstick lesbian
like crazy and [__] throw her into a
[__] teenage threesome and she'd
figure it out
smoke a joint listen to [__] Pink
Floyd
like everyone did like everybody has
some [__] Led Zeppelin House of the
Holy
71 that was a round one no no house was
the Holy I think was [__] like Mark
75 wasn't it uh she could listen to
Black Sabbath though that's true she'd
be listening to Black Sabbath
Zach said holy [__] having a three-way
to cover the fact you're gay that's
actually [__] genius Tom yeah yeah he
thinks of all these I [__] all the
air
she could have sex with that girl
through that boy
like or she can flip it any other way
she wants she'd figure it out she
figured out possibilities you don't know
we're all about the possibilities it
might resolve some issues and she just
decides she likes everything
yeah and like I said the shitty thing
you know it was 1979 uh you know like I
said mental health uh stuff wasn't the
way it was like people didn't really
understand it as well as they understand
it nowadays um people's understanding of
sexuality was not like it is nowadays so
I kind of feel like again I kind of feel
like if she was 16 now
um you know I don't think that she would
ever act out in this manner I could be
wrong about that but
I feel I you know some serial killers I
feel like you know what whenever they
were born they would probably just be
like a horrible [__] person but some
of the ones like I said like Jeffrey
Dahmer like people like that I think if
they were born in a different
era or you know were raised under
different circumstances they might have
turned out okay yeah and I kind of feel
like this girl maybe I mean I'm not
saying she doesn't have problems because
she does and like I said and it really
does trouble me that she doesn't seem to
still
um really take responsibility for what
she did because she's always kind of
trying to come up with excuses also I
don't think she's ever really reached a
level of emotional maturity because one
of the reasons more recently I believe
it was 2009 please forgive me if I'm
wrong but one of her
um parole hearings the reason they
didn't give her parole that time
was because she had um she had a
girlfriend in prison and they had broken
up and I guess it was like a bad breakup
and she took it really badly so she
um she took a a paper clip and heated it
up and like basically like carved
letters into herself so self-harm is
essentially so they were like well the
fact that you did that
shows that you can't really deal with
life you know what I mean because it was
just a breakup and it's like she
couldn't deal with it and you like
[__] cut you know you carved letters
into yourself
um and I believe that what she carved in
there she said it was runes uh and it's
and the words were Unforgiven and alone
those were the words she said she carved
in there so like I said in that I
believe that was 2009 so they're like
yeah again no parole for you she's
[__] drama queen and that's what I
mean so I do I'm living in captivity so
her right hasn't grown very much you
know I mean there's still kind of small
people not much outside experience with
life yeah I mean kind of she's still a
teenager yeah yeah she seemed kind of
yeah that's that's what I thought like I
was like that sounds like what something
a teenager would do and apparently
that's the parole board thought that as
well yeah well how do they expect her to
be normal right and that's the thing
well the weird thing about it is like I
saw another little bit of an interview
with her where she was talking about she
was excited about getting out like
during her some of her earlier parole
hearings because like I said she started
having Pearl hearings in 1993 but she
still hasn't got role
um you know they keep denying it and
then the last few years you can't really
just can't survive well yeah I don't
think she's ever gonna get released like
I said in California they said if you
did a murder like even if you have like
possibility of parole they hardly ever
let anybody out on parole that didn't
murder she could only be in some kind of
minimum security kind of assisted living
facility she can't have a civilian job
she couldn't survive just yeah because
well they were asking to be right back
in jail because she couldn't hang out
there yeah well like I said she's never
lived as an adult in like 1979 that was
a long time ago yeah you know what I
mean uh the world has changed like
immensely since then and I don't know if
she'll be able to deal with it she
didn't know the world even back then
right yeah I mean she seemed kind of
like isolated and out of it back then as
well so
that's the thing I mean like I said
during some of her like earlier parole
hearing she seemed like kind of excited
I think like during the ones they were
having in the 90s because she was like
oh she'd been
um you know training like she had all
these job skills and stuff like that
like they you know she would drop she
drove a forklift and all this other kind
of stuff so she was talking about oh I'm
gonna get out and I'm gonna be a
forklift driver and all this other [__]
but then like they didn't let her out
and then like they just kept not letting
her out every time just because every
time she had a parole hearing like I
said every time she would come up with
something different like the first time
she was like oh I was so drunk and high
I don't remember what happened and
they're like yeah we know that's not
true because we saw the toxicology
reports at which point she was like oh
well there was another set of toxicology
reports those were the fake ones that
were you know they're like okay whatever
um you know and then like at one thing
she was saying she didn't remember
anything that happened and then she was
saying oh my dad sexually abused me like
trying to get sympathy like I said I'm
not saying he didn't because he does
come across as kind of like a creeper
but um you know I know I realize he's
dead now and he can't defend himself I'm
just saying that's how he came across to
me so it's like I don't know if that's
false or not but still but it's just the
way she
you know and then I think at the last
parole hearing that they had where she
gave an excuse she actually said that's
right she said she was hallucinating and
that when she was shooting at people she
thought she was shooting at Commandos
that were attacking her she's full of
[__]
right so it's like so every single time
she keeps coming up with a new story
which is why they're not gonna let her
out I kind of feel like maybe she's
self-sabotaging I don't think she wants
to get out scared to come out
I mean I'd be scared to come out too if
I was her yeah
I'm just saying but she's all right in
there she's in an all-woman's prison
yeah
but I mean yeah so she likes girls she's
gonna be up there with those girls
that's you know
they'd be like locking me up with a
bunch of girls
oh my God they're locking me up in a
girl's school I mean I'm not gonna
survive I'm not gonna survive but get me
out of here what if they all want to Peg
you Tom yeah
she knows how to spin that [__] around
she's gonna spin a male Fantasy around
and [__] get you flaccided as a
[__] Okay yeah you got it it's
my superpower it's her superpowers
[__] up a man's dreams
I can't help it whenever somebody
whenever somebody has this big like
hopeful balloon they're blowing up I
just want to pop it yeah
I've always been like that I think I
understand I think I understand what
happened
you know it's teenage years it's hard
for everybody it is
for straight people though especially if
you if you're lucky and you're on your
game
your first experiences you know with
with [__] the opposite sex are quite
fun in high school quite satisfying
but for gay people especially back in
those days your first experience is of
course probably [__] a heartbreak
because the chances are there are any
other gay people at your high school
or no one that's going to admit it yeah
especially if it's not yeah
fall in love with somebody who [__]
is gonna think you're a freak so a lot
of them had to just hold on until they
were old enough to go to the nightclubs
before they could have a real life so
you know they're early experiences
[__] were heartache
yeah and that's probably what's
happening with this girl here
she's a lesbian or is or thinks she is
feels that she is you know
and uh she's not getting she's not
getting laid
and probably girl she likes doesn't want
anything to do there
so she goes down this path
she thinks she's a boy wants to shoot up
all the [__] cops
crap like that
threesome would have worked it out
though Zach I'm right I'm right about
that that worked it out
I mean how did you get her when she was
young I just again this is kind of a
thing where
it just always seems like there had to
be like a perfect storm of
factors that led up to this even though
it seems like
you know it seems like she was just
normal and then she woke up one day and
said hey I'm gonna shoot up a school you
know there were obviously things leading
up to that and she had planned it
because allegedly
um some of her classmates said that a
few days before the shooting or a week
before the shooting or something like
that she did actually say something to
the effect of oh I'm gonna do something
really big that's going to get me on TV
she's been thinking about it so yeah um
and some like on Once Upon a Crime she
was speculating that maybe Brenda did it
to impress her little Dirtbag friend
um you know like and show him that she
was like some big badass or something
like that because that that because they
always talked about that like they would
sit around and watch cop shows be like
yeah we're gonna plug something and [__]
like that and so like her actually doing
it because she did actually shoot a cop
he didn't die but it's funny is that
he's only 13. I think he was only 13. he
was kind of like a girlfriend isn't it
that's like a little Butch girlfriend
yeah I guess so that's her little that's
her little Butch girlfriend but that's
did you see that's not satisfying her
either because that's not a real girl
that's not a real little Bunch girl yeah
that's just a little boy it's just a
little 13. it's just a little 13 year
old boy but that's that's her surrogate
who's who's a little little miscreant
yeah
she's she's witching that she's wishing
that that was a girl and that she was
[__] 17 and just like that
because if you ask me about a lot of
little budget a lot of Butch girls he
has me they're just like little boys
that's how they come across from anytime
they feel they don't feel like man they
feel like little boys I mean they're
like they're emulating this fashion cues
too of boys
but they find that attractive
so yeah that's that's her little Butch
girlfriend the 13 year old boy nacho
event
and maybe it was and honestly like I
said you know on that podcast I was kind
of like
it did seem like that might have been a
factor that she was trying to impress
that kid yeah because that was because
apparently that was something they
talked about all the time yeah like
doing these kind of violent especially
shooting cops they were really into like
they really wanted to shoot but then
there's like there's the dynamic that he
is actually the opposite sex of her
so in a weird way it's heterosexuality
it's fantasizing that it's lesbianism
but it's actually heterosexuality
well I get the the Mind plays funny
tricks but I guarantee you that all this
kind of [__] is going on in her head so
there's a lot of conflict
yeah I mean clearly because it's not
making any sense to her there had to
have been for her to just do this
right and to be so
callous about it the way she was just
she must have somehow disassociated from
herself it seemed very well and like I
said it's her family seemed very yeah
emotionally distant from one another so
I imagine maybe dissociation for himself
naturally so now she's seeing herself
from the outside
yeah and and so she's seeing herself
from the outside doing all this
she's not really in charge she's seeing
herself shoot all these people
and she's like you know look at her go
you know it's just it's gonna be
something what a badass what a badass
look at her gup my little 13 year old
Butch boy girlfriend will love me it's
it's gonna be something like that yeah I
just that's just my feelings about it
and and my gut has been I've always
learned to trust my gut in the end that
[__] [__] that's usually what it is
because I don't know
I can call it
I think in a lot of ways she wanted
attention to you because she wasn't
getting this is the love and attention
she wasn't getting any attention from
her family she wasn't getting any
attention from schoolmates or friends
home life right she was just very
isolated and lonely I imagine and then
she had a prison cell mate her dad ran
off with her
and she was like her but not like her
I think maybe she kind of felt that was
rejection Maybe
so I mean that would be super her dad
replaced her I can't imagine her dad
replaced her with a girl that was just
like her
and then she lost that girl to her dad
if she thought it was her girlfriend
socialist rejection from both of them
yeah
yeah I mean you might have a point there
that might be exactly how she saw it
yeah he came and stole my girlfriend
yeah yeah and he replaced me with her
right yeah so it's like what you know
what use am I like yeah just like the
third wheel exactly exactly yeah I get
it so there's that angle
yeah
but I mean
it's a [__] up case man so like I said
it's all real subtle yeah all right it's
it's but I think we're on it I think
that's what it is yeah I think it was a
combination yeah like I said she you
know she had like a head injury too
which like I said very common well what
that does is that just really that just
removes a little bit of her inhibition
sure so it allows it to happen but it
doesn't make her doesn't really change
what she thinks right it just makes it
easier for her to act on what she's
thinking about yeah like having a drink
at a [__] six-pack loosen you up a
little bit Yeah and then suddenly you're
just like [__] that you you stupid [__]
that you wouldn't do when you were sober
all of a sudden it's like oh my God what
a good idea that is right then the next
day you're like that was really not a
good idea
what was I thinking
exactly
but yeah so uh as I mentioned earlier uh
not too long after the shooting
um you know Bob Geldof actually heard
about the shooting
um when he was in the United States and
it fascinated him so much that he wrote
a song about it yeah Bob Geldof was the
original Bono Bono he was the original
Bono that's where Bono learned to be a
douchebag he learned that [__] from
[__] Bob gildoff he's a [__]
douche yeah now I would argue that Bono
is a way bigger dude much bigger much
bigger but much bigger yeah and then the
biggest [__] out of him all would have
been sting I don't know I feel like not
because
it's just that he was always trying to
[__] your woman using his tantric energy
yeah his [__] was a prick [__] a
smirky ass [__] prick you know he's
trying to [__] your woman look at sting
just look although I will give sting
credit because he never really seems to
hide it no you know exactly what it is
when you see it so it's gonna sit so I
think he's the best out of all of them
because at least he's not like trying to
be he's the most dangerous about it he's
the most dangerous he's the most
dangerous okay
I'm the rock star because he will
[__] sit there in the Lotus position
and your wife will climb up climb up
upon his Langham
in the Lotus position he won't even
thrust nope he doesn't need to doesn't
need thrust just with [__] pure
spiritual power he just busted that
it's amazing really yeah when you think
about it yeah yeah it's a secret it's a
secret it's all that yoga and [__] Yoga
Yoga yogurt
ew yeah
that's for that image yeah
[Laughter]
video about it
we can reenact that right over there
in a Lotus position
oh my god let's do it let's oh my God
that would be so funny nobody would
understand it oh my God that'd be so
funny I have you with four arms like
Kylie and [__] that would be hilarious
you're gonna have to do some of those
Indian dances and [__] okay all right
have you blue and everything paint your
blue like not only skulls and [__] I was
gonna do that for Halloween one year
until I figured out yeah and I would be
dressed up as sting sting and probably
yeah I mean admittedly it's a little you
got to go a little way to get there but
it's like I don't know I think it would
be really funny I mean it would be funny
to me anyway and that's all that matters
yeah Camp guy said sting nothing like
the sun is a great album it is actually
I used to have it on vinyl I don't think
I have it anymore
but yeah so um so yeah so the Boomtown
Rats did that song uh I Don't Like
Mondays which like I said even though it
did get some radio play here in the
United States enough so that like in San
Diego like a San Diego radio stations
were like yeah we're not playing that um
because people hear a little sensitive
about it as you might imagine
um but it did get some radio play like
in some other larger markets in the US
it didn't chart here I don't think but
um it was number one for like a month in
the UK and like a bunch of other
countries
it was a huge hit uh over there too and
like I said I heard it over here like in
there probably not 1979 but I heard it
like in their early 80s for sure
um but yeah that's what I didn't know
back then that it was based on what it
was based on though I only found that
out like probably in the mid 80s uh who
it was talking about but I don't know
what he was talking about like because
in the lyrics he talking about it's
silicone chip inside her head like [__]
I like I said I guess they were trying
to like imply that maybe she was like a
Manchurian Candidate or something but it
wasn't that I mean she did have
um you know a head injury and she had
epilepsy and stuff but
I don't think there was anything
there was any like weird MK Ultra [__]
or anything like that so um as I said uh
she Brenda was actually like happy that
he had written that song because it made
her famous because like I said she just
wanted attention so I think she was
happy about anything that made her
famous note that she wouldn't you know
when she was
holed up in the house like after the
shooting she wouldn't come out until she
was sure that TV cameras were there and
then she made sure that she was gonna
get on TV like with handcuffs on you
know what I mean like so I've heard
so she it was very important to her that
she came across like that
so yeah
um I guess we're gonna wrap this up
because we've been on for more than two
hours and I have to go to bed soon
because you know how it is having to get
up early and all that other kind of [__]
like I have to do yeah Oscar and Miss
Kitty were like you guys are gonna go
cam to cam with us and I said man she's
gonna go to sleep man well uh yeah well
I we were talking to we talked to Misty
a little bit last night over FaceTime
yeah but yeah I was getting listening
now I was getting to be yeah it was
going to be 10 o'clock and I was like oh
man I'm like and I was like dozing off
you know what I mean because well you
know it's like I feel bad but it's I
know that 10 o'clock is very early and I
feel like an old person but well yeah
and they're in another time zone and
they're in another time zone too like
we're in Eastern Standard they're like
in Texas so I'm just kind of like
um it's earlier for this you know I know
it's like an old lady thing to go to bed
at 10 but I'm like 4 30. I get up at
like 4 30 or 5 in the morning yeah and I
have to I have to be at work in Daytona
like an hour away like at 7 30. yeah so
I have so I have to get up earlier yeah
I leave the house at like 6 15. [__]
weekdays weekdays she works all [__]
day okay and then she works all night
when she comes home on the weekdays yeah
actually when I got she knows all the
other projects when I got home today
like you know you had made me say like
he like he left me a salad like on my
desk like when I came home like a nice
big salad with turkey on it everything
and I was like awesome so like I ate
that and then I had two
graphic design jobs to do yeah like like
thankfully they were just like small
ones so I got them done like pretty
quick and then I had to go through my
notes for the show again and make sure
that everything that I wanted to be in
there was in there and like you know set
up everything for that so Jack said
something about sting what are you
saying uh oh [__] sting I never realized
how creepy the lyrics to Every Breath
You Take are oh yeah yeah and after I
heard it yeah we'll see that's the thing
and sting himself even said that I mean
he acknowledged he's like I wrote that
about a [__] stalker you know what I
mean yeah it's not a normal dude but
he's like um I saw about an interview
like a long time this is a long time ago
but he said you know he's like I have
people come up to me and go I got
married to that song and he's like okay
so popular and was so misunderstood that
he felt guilty I I [__] with sting I I
have a lot of respect for State like we
love the police yeah like I listen to
police in the car all the time yeah he's
he's real talented he's very he's
extremely witty
but because uh Every Breath You Take got
so popular he felt guilty about it
because people [__] thought that that
was a healthy like a love song love song
and he's like no so when he went solo he
wrote a response to that called set them
free yeah if you love somebody and
that's he says this is what I really
believe yeah and you know he's a which
you know it's a good it's a good lesson
that song but you gotta understand you
know he's also kind of like a a a
polyamorous type dude when you're
staying you're going to be a woman
collector probably
because why wouldn't you if you can get
one beautiful women and you can get a
second one and a third one why not and I
kind of thinking collect them all
collect them all collect them all and
you're rich enough to take care of them
all they're all like Pokemon send them
all out shopping together [__] yeah
I mean
that's so funny though that anybody
would think that Every Breath You Take
was like a romantic song no [__]
I was like that's a stalker song yeah
and he wrote it as a stalker song yeah
at the time at the time yeah yeah so it
wasn't meant to be a healthy example no
no no he's like he was writing as like
Ultra control it was a maximum control
[__] because you don't want
somebody that's like [__] crawling up
your ass 24 7. just thinking about you
no matter where you are and Every Breath
You Take every step you there I'll be
right there with you no no no no I'm
like uh no thanks I don't like that yeah
so listen to [__] listen to [__] off
the dream of the blue turtles album
[__] if you love someone said yeah I
think it's a call if you love somebody
yeah so there's parentheses yeah yeah
yeah yeah they played in the club every
now and then it's a good song well it's
weird because every like when you talk
about Every Breath You Take into that
being like a toxic relationship and
people like really misinterpreting that
I kind of feel like the same thing
happened I'm gonna say the same thing
happened with the [__] um Twilight
books and the 50 Shades of Gray books
um so many women got into those books oh
well it's so romantic and so I'm like
that's not romantic that's [__] up I
was like those are toxic relationships
that they are talking about and the fact
that like people are reading those like
thinking that
um thinking that that's good or that's
something to like aspire to I'm like no
that's gonna be a bad time for everyone
involved I'm like those are horrible
controlling relationships and you really
it's just Red Flag City is what is going
on in that and it's the same thing with
Every Breath You Take and it's just kind
of alarming that like people
uh kind of aspire to those kind of
relationships like I don't I don't want
some like dude that like climbs in my
window and it's like watching me sleep
yeah that's creepy yeah that's not
romantic that's [__] creepy yeah a
lot of stuff that's why I don't like
rom-coms because a lot of stuff that
happens at rom-coms is straight up
[__] creepy I'm like if that like
that's stalker behavior I'm like they
would report people to the cops for that
nowadays yeah some of the [__] that they
do in rom-coms it's like oh it's so
romantic I'm like no it's really not
it's [__] creepy uh Trey says Hey
guys YouTube is having issues for me
tonight the audio is out of sync no
matter what I play so I'll have to
listen to this one later yeah well it's
almost over and see you soon yeah I mean
yeah it's it's fine like because we're
show's over yeah it's we've already been
on for two hours and 15 minutes yeah
it's time and like I said I gotta clean
up and go to bed because it's almost 10
o'clock almost my bedtime yeah that's
old ladies
but anyway I think this turned out a
good show this was like I said this was
an interesting topic I've always been
kind of fascinated by this girl
just because it's so unusual and I still
don't know what the [__] I mean I kind
of know what her deal is but geez uh
yeah Trey said I tried to watch several
times yeah it must be I guess it's
YouTube all over because our audio is in
sync here but I have that problem with
YouTube sometimes too but not that often
all right so we're gonna wrap it up for
this Wednesday evening thank you very
much Mrs Evans already party thanks for
the show she says thank you very much
for the Super Chat so thanks you guys
for dropping by this evening hope you
guys enjoyed the show
um we will be back on Friday night for
our Infamous Side Track show where we'll
be talking about God knows what you know
how we do having drinks and whatnot so
hopefully you can join us for that so
we'll see you guys again on Friday night
good night